Schreibt mir in die Kommentare, wie du mit dem Video gefilmt hast.
Ich würde mich über einen Daumen nach oben freuen.
Wenn du meinen Kanal abonnierst.
Das war's für heute. Ich hoffe, dass euch das Video gefallen hat.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, schreibt mir in die Kommentare.
So Leute, ist euch schon aufgefallen, dass Twitch irgendwie komisch aussieht?
Oh, ich muss mir was aufschreiben.
Ich muss morgen mein Unity Media Zeugs zurückschicken.
Wenn ich morgen mein Unity Media Zeugs nicht zurückschicke, dann kostet es Geld.
Die sind ganz furchtbar bescheiden bei Unity Media.
Ich lese euch das mal kurz vor.
Und zwar, erstmal haben die mir irgendwie gefühlt 50 Seiten oder so geschickt.
Oh, jetzt war es mal auf.
Bitte schicken sie uns folgende Hardware zurück.
Ein Digital TV Rekorde HD und eine Smart Card.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Das Ding ist, also das Unity Media Teil.
Ich hab das zum Glück noch.
So, das ist dieses olle Ding von Unity Media, da, noch älter.
Das da, das Ding von Unity Media, das ist, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahre alt oder sechs Jahre
alt.
Und wisst ihr, was die mir hier quasi, ich nenne es mal, androhen, was es kostet, wenn
ich das nicht zurückschicke?
Also was die damit machen, wenn ich es zurückschicke, ist, die schmeißen es auf den Schrott.
Swiss Shock, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Pock.
Sag mal, heute bin ich wieder lauter als gestern, ich blick's irgendwie nicht.
So, und Unity Media sagt, das kostet mich 200 Euro, wenn ich das Ding nicht mehr zurückschicke.
Sind die irgendwie noch ganz dicht?
So, und dann, sag mal, irgendwie, warum bin ich, ist entweder, sind meine Ohren heute irgendwie
besser oder ich bin, ich bin lauter, aber ich bin nicht lauter, ne, sehe ich ja hier,
ich bin nicht lauter.
Ich bin, ich bin einseitig, oder, ich bin links, ich bin links ein bisschen lauter als
rechts, kann das sein?
Normale Lautstärke, okay, so, links lauter als rechts, okay, wie dem auch sei, wahrscheinlich
ist mein Ohr einfach gerade am failen, zumindest, dafür soll ich 200 Euro bezahlen, wenn ich
das nicht zurückschicke.
Und dann ist noch eine Smartcard dabei, die angeblich so ein publisches Stück Plastik,
die 35 Euro wert ist, wenn ich das nicht zurückschicke, demnächst, also morgen am besten, dann soll
ich 100, 235 Euro an Unity Media bezahlen für zwei Geräte, die die direkt schrotten
werden.
Vorne ist das ganze noch voller Rechtsbelehrung, was ich jetzt hier geiles Neues bei Unity
Media unterschrieben hab, ich sag dir heute, wir haben hier einen Berg geschickt.
Und das beste ist hier, kommt jetzt gleich, was ich jetzt, also mein Tarif bei Unity Media,
den ich jetzt habe, der nennt sich jetzt Treue Plus 3 Play 400, Treue Plus, das soll mir
jetzt irgendwie so das Gefühl geben, ich bin was besonderes bei Unity Media.
So, und hier haben sie lustigerweise, ich geh mal davon aus, weil sie das gesetzlich müssen,
haben sie einen Zettel dabei gelegt, Übertragungsraten, maximal, normalerweise zur Verfügung stehen
und garantiert.
Das Ding hat einen Skatanschluss, aber, aber wie das noch einen Skatanschluss hat, sogar
das neue, sogar das ganz neue von Unity Media, was ich gekriegt hab, hat noch einen Skatanschluss.
So, pass mal auf, ich bezahl für maximal 400 Down, 40 Up, garantiert, garantiert 160 Down
und 16 Up.
Dass man sowas überhaupt verkaufen darf, dass man sowas überhaupt verkaufen darf,
neuer Mod, ja, ja, neuer Mod, ich hab Sellout gemacht, Chuck690 hat 20 Subs gegiftet, ich
hab gesagt, wer 20 Subs gifftet, kriegt Mod, aber ich hab nicht gesagt, für wie lange.
Foxlite, das ist Korruption, ja und, hast du Probleme damit, oder, ich nicht, hab damit
überhaupt keine Schmerzen.
Was kostet, gucken wir nächsten Monat, gucken, wieviel ich noch brauche nächsten Monat.
Ja, und das ganze verlängert sich um einfach 24 Monate, aber ich find's geil, dass man
sowas, du bist schon, klar kenn ich dich noch, wir haben CS gespielt und davor glaub ich
noch vom Minecraft Server, oder, glaub schon, klar, ja also mein alles vergess ich auch
nicht, alles vergess ich auch nicht, aber ich find's geil, dass man sowas verkaufen
darf, oder, man verkauft 40 Down und 40 Up und garantiert sind nur 160, 16, von Hard,
er sieht Baro, du würdest dir wahrscheinlich am liebsten das Physiken Grill kaufen, ne,
wenn ich das so im Discord richtig verprätige, ja locker, übrigens Leute, ich muss euch
noch was erzählen, aber, ihr kennt ja das Video wahrscheinlich, was ich gemacht hab
hier, ne, ich sag mal irritiert euch die neue Schriftart auf Twitch auch, voll irritiert,
was ist das überhaupt für eine Schriftart auf Twitch, komm wir gucken jetzt mal was
das für eine heißt, ich will wissen wie die Schriftart von Twitch heißt, also ersten,
finde ich, wenn ich mir das neue Twitch Design angucke, dass es jetzt aussieht wie so eine
Fake Twitch Seite, kennt ihr diese Seiten, die so aussehen wollen wie Twitch, aber nicht
schaffen um quasi den Leuten ihre Accounts zu klauen, so sieht Twitch jetzt selber aus,
wie so eine Fake Twitch Seite, die aussehen wie Twitch, aber nicht Twitch ist, aber natürlich
Dark Mode muss man als erstes einschalten, ganz klar, Dark Mode ist jetzt nicht mal graus,
sondern Dark Mode ist einfach komplett zu null, da gibt es nix, aber wir müssen mal gucken
was das für eine Schrift, was ist das denn für eine Schrift, was ist das, ihr Elfer,
was ist das für eine Schriftart, was ist das, was ist das, meine Fre... ach du Sch... wie
viele Diffs haben die Jungs denn hier im Inneneinander, ja was ist das, ja was ist das denn, 5Head
Webdesign sag ich dazu nur, aber ganz ehrlich Leute, ich glaube, dass Twitch bessere Webdesign
Leute hat als ich es bin, deswegen glaube ich, dass den jetzt einfach mal, Moment, der
Font von Twitch heißt Robert, richtig, Robert, warum heißt der Font von Twitch Robert, ja,
ist der Twitch Font, Robert, Robert heißt der Twitch Font, ja warum das dann, ja guckt
euch an, der Twitch Font, was kostet er denn zu kaufen, 6,60€, easy, Web ist noch teurer,
wow alles, ja Geld, Money, alles, ich will Robert, in allen Varianten will ich Robert
haben, Robert, ok, keine Ahnung, Robert komplett kostet 2244€, ein freches Design, also ich
muss sagen, normalerweise bin ich ja jemand, der sich immer ein bisschen gewöhnen muss
an neue Designs, ich finde, dass diesmal es geht, ja, es geht, es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig
das Twitch Design, insofern, ich gehe mal kurz auf, dass es hier noch das alte grau
ist und hier irgendwie einfach nur, ja, also hier ist es komplett dunkel, komplett schwarz
der Hintergrund, ja, komplett schwarz und Darkraft wie Master, komisch, also ich muss
euch ehrlich sagen, rein optisch fand ich das grau schöner, also hier grau da, ein
bisschen helleres grau da oder so, einfach schwarz, ich dachte auch, die haben ihr CSS
vergesst, dachte ich am Anfang auch, als ich die Seite aufgemacht habe, dass die ihr CSS
nicht richtig laden, aber ne, die meinen das, die meinen das wirklich, das prinzipielle
Beschwerden über jede Änderung ist peinlich, warum, werden ist immer, erstmal Beschwerden,
ja, erstmal Beschwerden, die Twitch Seite an sich ist ok, da hat sich ja nicht viel
geändert, das ist ja reine optische Geschichte, das ist ja nicht wie Twitch, wie Twitter,
die quasi erstmal komplett die Bedienung der Seite umgekrempelt haben und ich heute immer
noch so meine, oh, was gibt es denn für ASMR Grills, es mache nur Grills, ASMR auf Twitch,
erstmal hier das elfen Cosplay, naja zumindest finde ich die Farben jetzt nicht gerade gelungen,
muss ich jetzt echt sagen, so einfach, guck mal, Katz ist am Start, ne, ich weiß nicht,
warum haben wir hier Slots gespielt, naja, so, es ist ok, ich spekuliere ja persönlich
drauf, dass die einfach wieder ein besseres Theme in Franker Faces Z machen als das offizielle,
weil das letzte FFZ Theme war viel besser als das offizielle Twitch Theme und dann ist
wieder alles gut, ist das eigentlich eine neue Katze, ja, das ist meine dritte Katze,
die ich jetzt hier seit wir umgezogen sind habe, das war ja die erste, die erste Katze
die ich hatte war ja, war die hier, das war Original Katz FPS, danach hatte ich die hier
und jetzt habe ich die hier und was lustig ist, die sehen alle ganz anders aus, ne, die
war so grau gestreift, die war schwarz-weiß und die hier ist jetzt rot-weiß-schwarz, warum
kein Hund, weil ich Katzen lieber mag als Hunde, ganz einfach, Bugs Hände Confirmed,
also ich muss euch was erzählen und zwar, ich hab's heute auf Twitter geschrieben, ihr
kennt ja wahrscheinlich alle mein Homeoffice Video und ich bin heute Morgen, mein Chef
war irgendwie gestern nicht da, ich bin heute Morgen mal zu meinem Chef hin und war ein bisschen
abgelästert über die Azure Schulung, dass die irgendwie sackt, ja und irgendwie hat
er mir dann erzählt, Bugs, ich hab dein Homeoffice Video gesehen, da hab ich dann erstmal gedacht
hier, so, hab ich erstmal gedacht, dachte ich erstmal, auf der anderen Seite ist es
auch nicht schlimm, weil ich weiß, dass der das guckt ab und zu, ich glaube im Stream,
warum hast du in so einer kurzen Zeit so viele Katzen, ja weil ich ein bisschen Pech hatte
oder die Katze, je nachdem, wie man sieht, ja, hast du ein Firmenauto, nee hab ich nicht,
hab nur ein Firmenhandy, iPhone XR, hab ich jetzt gewogenermaßen, wohnst du an einer
vielbefahrenen Straße, naja, es geht, naja zumindest hat er mir das dann erzählt, dass
er mal ein Video geguckt hat, dachte erstmal so um OKS, aber wie gesagt, ich mein ich weiß
ja, dass er das guckt teilweise, also eigentlich nichts Schlimmes, aber wir müssen das, wir
müssen uns das jetzt nochmal anhören und mal gucken, ob ich irgendwas doofes gesagt
hab, wir müssen das gerade nochmal reinhören, ich hab nämlich keine Ahnung mehr, was ich
gesagt hab, nee, nee, als, nee, nee, nix Schlimmes, nix, also wir müssen, wir müssen
das gerade nochmal reinhören, ob ich irgendwas doofes gesagt hab, also Leute, zwölf, zwölf
Minuten, ach so ja, das mit dem Schlafanzug hat er gesagt, er hat gesagt, dass er, er
hat gesagt, ja dann machen wir am Freitag keine Videokonferenz, hat er gesagt, sieht
dein Chef auch, dass du während der Arbeitszeit twitterst, ich mach hier Nachrichten, also
typ potenziell kann er das sehen, aber ganz ehrlich, der hat damit keine Schmerzen, solange
das läuft, ich mein ich krieg eh, ob ich's will oder nicht, gewisse Zeit an Pause abgezogen,
nachdem ich kaum essen geh, ist das echt ein Ding, ich habe noch irgendwo, ich weiß nicht
wo, hab ich in Battlefield 3 Heli Gameplay von meinem jetzigen Chef, ich weiß nicht
wo, sonst würd ich das nochmal rausbuddeln, der war in Battlefield 3 auf der PS3, der
war immer Helikreisler, der Dude war immer richtig toxic, keine Ahnung, du meinst, der
von dem das Gameplay ist, das ist hier Hexe, von dem hab ich viele Gameplays immer, ist
dein Chef älter oder jünger als du, der ist ein bisschen älter, der ist ein bisschen
älter, ich würd mal sagen so 2-3 Jahre, aber ich glaube 40 ist er auch noch nicht, ich
glaube der wird so 38 oder so sein, ja das Gameplay ist aber von Hexe, ach so, ah, du
meinst den der im Team hat, ok keine Ahnung, den kenn ich nicht, also Leute wir müssen
uns jetzt mal kurz anhören, was ich da so erzähle und mal checken, muss ich mich jetzt
mal in meinen Chef reinversetzen, hast du das Gameplay schon mal benutzt, nee, das Gameplay
ist 2 Monate als Kanter nicht benutzt haben, muss ich mich mal kurz, oh Leute, ich bin
übelst aufs Klo, ich bin gleich wieder da, ihr könnt euch jetzt Modern Warfare 2 was
unterrated ankommen, aber ich mach mal seinen Commentary aus, wir wollen jetzt nicht komplett,
Scheiß drauf, ich muss mal kacken Leute, ich bin gleich wieder da.
ich bin gleich wieder da, ich muss mal kacken Leute, ich bin gleich wieder da,
ich muss mal kacken Leute, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich muss mal kacken Leute, ich
Das war's für heute.
Eine strafe.
Es geht smashen!
Mal schauen.
Die.
Emily.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag nix gegessen. Ich hab nur mal morgens, morgens hab ich ein bisschen Baguette gefuttert und den ganzen Tag nix, und als ich heimgegangen bin, hab ich mir einen Döner Teller geholt.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Typ in den Döner Teller reingemacht hat, aber es kann sein, dass ich irgendwie noch ab und zu mal...
Wuppelull heißt es übrigens nicht, sondern... Wuppelull, achso, doch, du hast ja richtig geschrieben. Wuppelull.
Wenn man sich seine eigenen, wenn man seine eigenen Emotes nicht kennt, oder?
So, jetzt müssen wir uns, ups, jetzt müssen wir uns das Ganze noch mal angucken, ob ich irgendwas Blödes gesagt habe, woran man sich stören könnte, wenn man das Video auf der Arbeit hört.
So, auf geht's über das Thema Homeoffice auslassen. Es kommt der letzte Zeit öfters mal immer wieder auf laut genug das Video, vor allem wenn es um die Themen so Infrastruktur und Umweltschutz und sowas geht, da kommen ja immer wieder Leute auf die Idee so nach dem Motto, ah, na das bringt schon richtig was, wenn die Leute alle von daheim arbeiten, da müssen die sich morgen nicht mehr in die Bahn setzen oder so, keine Autos mehr haben oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Deswegen wollte ich mich mal ein Video dazu auslassen, was ich da so für Vor- und Nachteile sehe und was ich da persönlich dafür...
Ja, das ist richtig, Maxception, das ist jetzt quasi past Max, past Max, allerdings dadurch, dass wir es im Stream gucken, wird es automatisch Present Max und es ist auf jeden Fall, braucht man Big Brain dafür, Erfahrungen mitgemacht habe.
Übrigens, das Fazitvideo zur Modern Warfare Beta werde ich wahrscheinlich morgen oder übermorgen erst hochladen, ha ha ha, Max Null, weil ich muss gerade jeden Tag bis 17 Uhr einen Microsoft Azure Kurs machen, ja das ist, ich sag euch Leute, das ist Hyper Resident Sleeper, das ist mega langweilig.
Ja, aber weiter zum Thema Homeoffice, das Ganze ja früher auch Telearbeit genannt, aber wer das heute noch so nennt, der macht wahrscheinlich seine Präsentationen auch noch mit Overhead Projekte oder sowas.
Kurz was zu mir, ich hab's ja im Video über die ganze Router-Config schon gesagt, ich bin 35, arbeite in Frankfurt als DevOps-Engineer bei einer Bank und in meinem Beruf ist das eigentlich kein Problem ab und zu mal...
Ja gut, ich kann Ihnen ja nicht genau erzählen, wo ich arbeite oder teilweise manche Leute sogar dauerhaft das von daheim zu arbeiten, ich mach das auch regelmäßig und übrigens Leute, wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt, jetzt Herr Talas Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Prime, Prime, Prime, Nice, Subscriber.
Äh, hab ich Subs übersehen? Sekunde Leute, ne hab ich nicht. Das ist der beste Zeitpunkt den Abo-Button zu drücken, damit ihr jede Menge weitere Videos bekommt, die ihr dann... doch ich hab tatsächlich irgendwas übersehen, The Hook hab ich übersehen. Ja gut, da war ich grad aufm Klo, wie soll ich das aufm Klo sehen?
Ja gut, 2 Monate Prime, Subscriber.
Nice, Subscriber.
Einfach laufen lassen. Was? Ok, ja was denn du?
Aber es ist natürlich super, wenn wir, sag mal, ich kann bis 7 Uhr pennen, das macht natürlich einen Unterschied. Das ist eine Stunde vorne weg, wo ich länger schlafen kann, was natürlich auch dazu führt, dass wenn man die ganze Woche schon am Start gewesen ist, dass es einfach eine angenehme Geschichte ist, dass man einfach mal eine Stunde länger pennen kann, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Ich arbeite übrigens immer noch Teilzeit, hatte letztens in einem der Videos mal jemand gefragt. Also ich arbeite gar nicht mehr 5 Tage die Woche, schon seit den letzten paar Jahren nicht. Aber da mach ich mein eigenes Video zu. Ähm, ich wollte generell mein eigenes Video zum Thema Arbeiten, IT-Karriere und Teilzeit-Arbeiten, sowas machen.
Wenn ihr das sehen wollt, schreibt schon in die Kommentare rein, ihr wisst ja, ich lese prinzipiell alle Comments. Einen Punkt hab ich jetzt auch schon angesprochen, der natürlich auch für Homeoffice spricht, man muss sich mit keinem Mist in der Bahn rumschlagen morgens.
Wisst ihr Leute, immer wenn ich was aufschreibe, frage ich mich, Max, wozu machst du das überhaupt? Das ist immer anders.
Was machst du das überhaupt? Du hast eine Bash-Historie von 150.000 Zeilen, das muss reichen, du musst nichts mehr aufschreiben. Aber leider sehen die Leute, ist so, ich weiß, ich kenn das noch jemand.
Kennt das noch jemand? Wozu soll ich was aufschreiben, wenn ich das alles in meiner Historie drin stehen hab?
Viele andere Leute, das ist immer anders. Deswegen muss ich doch ab und zu was aufschreiben.
Ja, ich mach gerne Sachen, ich mach gerne ruhigere Sachen daheim, wo man ein bisschen seine Ruhe braucht dazu.
Programmieren ist da eigentlich so eine hauptsächliche Sache, die sich wirklich anbietet, weil leider haben sich das viele Unternehmen mittlerweile überlegt, dass Großraumbüros was ganz Tolles sind.
Ja, Großraumbüros sind ultrabeknackt. Was ist, wenn der Rechner abschmiert, dann bleibt die Bash-Historie erhalten. Bash-Historie bleibt da.
Das ist kein Problem.
Max muss aufpassen, dass er sich nicht obsolet automatisiert.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja dann viel eher, wer die Automatisierung automatisiert.
Das muss ja immer noch jemand machen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das in den USA oder so mal vor ein paar Jahren hip gewesen ist. Da sind jetzt auch schon wirklich einige...
Oh, ich bin so, ey, als ich diesen Play von der Hexe gesehen hab, ich bin so beruhigt, dass es nicht nur mir so geht. Kennt ihr das?
Oder so mal vor ein paar Jahren.
Ihr aimt in die Richtung, weil ihr denkt, der Gegner läuft in die Richtung und dann macht er auf einmal so eine ganz kurze Bewegung nach links und ihr könnt es überhaupt nicht matchen richtig, die Bewegung.
Ich bin ja froh, dass das der Hexe auch passiert, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin, der manchmal so komische Dinge macht.
Was mich auch beruhigt ist, dass man daran sieht, man kann das gar nicht. Manche Sachen kann man nicht predicten.
Ich komme mir immer richtig dumm vor, wenn ich in Modern Warfare irgendwie so mache bei den Gegnern, aber das liegt einfach daran, weil die irgendwie kaum interpoliert werden.
Die sind irgendwie so wupp wupp. Kennst du Hexe persönlich? Nö.
Da sind jetzt auch schon mit einigen auf den Drichter gekommen, das ist doch nicht so geil, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht.
Aber man kann sich in Großraumbüros, wenn man sich wirklich konzentrieren muss, kann man sich relativ schlecht konzentrieren.
Deswegen, wenn ich Sachen habe, wo ich mich wirklich mal ein paar Stunden am Stück konzentrieren muss, dann geht das daheim am besten.
Erstens ist es da ruhiger und außerdem ist es auch entspannter und ich habe schon öfters gesagt, Programmieren ist was Kreatives, auch wenn das viele Leute nicht so sehen.
Das sage ich auf der Arbeit ja auch immer.
Aber ich glaube, die meisten Leute, die selbst programmieren werden, sind da nichts Verwerfliches dran. Umso entspannter man ist, umso bessere Ideen hat man natürlich auch.
Zweiter Punkt ist, der auch oftmals außen vor gelassen wird, viele wollen gar nicht Homeoffice machen.
Zum Beispiel, wir haben jemand auf der Arbeit, Vater mit vier Kindern, alles Mädels, ohne Frau daheim.
Und bei dem war es früher regelmäßig so, dass alle, der Typ ist eh geil, von dem ich da erzähle auf der Arbeit, der Typ ist eh geil.
Auf der Arbeit ist er übelst hektisch, immer wenn irgendetwas ist, ist er so, der hängt den ganzen Tag da.
Und ist voll hypernate, so im Ruhemodus.
Und sobald was ist, sobald irgendein Ticket aufploppt, oder noch schlimmer, ist irgendwas kaputt, dann wacht er so in Gefühlen fünf Millisekunden aus seinem Ruhemodus auf.
Das ist dann wirklich so, Ticket plopploppt, so was ist jetzt gewesen, jetzt müssen wir gleich gucken, jetzt müssen wir gleich das Ticket eintragen.
Moment Leute, ich mach schon das Ticket auf, ich mach das Ticket auf, so hast du schon mal nachgeguckt, was mit dem hier passiert.
Hier guck mal, mach mal das Monitoring auf, mach mal das Monitoring auf, hier guck mal, da, da, hier, da ist es, da ist es.
Wie sieht der Graph von gestern aus? Ah okay, ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Okay Leute, so wäre das spannend.
So geht das bei dem, das ist ganz schwer, das habe ich noch nie gesehen vorher.
Von Hibernate auf Hipernate, ja ist echt so, ist echt so, ich hab das noch nie, ich hab das noch nie anderweitig erlebt.
Kennt ihr Leute, die gerne auf eurem, auf eurem Monitor rumtatschen und dort Dinger zeigen, das geht mir immer voll, das triggert mich immer voll.
Allerdings bei ihm triggert mich das nicht, weil der hat so eine ganze, der hat so eine lustige Art, Sachen auf dem Monitor zu zeigen.
Der, weiß ich nicht, manche Leute schmieren immer so halt mit dem Finger über den Monitor um was zu zeigen.
Der, der sticht mit dem Finger so auf den Monitor.
Ich hatte bei dem alten Monitor schon Angst, dass der Finger hinten wieder rauskommt.
Wisst ihr, der, der, der, der, der sticht so mit dem Finger, so nach dem Motto, wenn ich das jetzt mit Papier nachmachen müsste, so nach dem Motto so, da, da.
Da, voll mit dem Finger, ich dachte vom alten Monitor schon demnächst, der Finger ist entweder ab oder der Monitor kaputt.
Der ist geil, Typ.
Alle Viertelstunde, halbe Stunde das Telefon geklingelt hat und einer abartig ins Telefon reingekriegelt hat, Papa, was weiß ich, die hat die Hello Kitty Decke geklaut.
Das hat nicht so hart abgelöst, das hat abgemalt und ich lässt den nicht ab.
Ich hab sogar gesagt, dass ich, wo ist das Problem noch zu sagen, dass man sowas dann nicht erlebt hat.
Aber das war echt früher witzig.
Also da haben alle, alle Viertelstunde oder so, oder halbe Stunde, haben dann entweder die Kinder oder die Frau angerufen und hab halt ins Telefon reingeschrien.
Und da ging es wirklich um so Sachen wie, die eine Tochter hat der andere die Hello Kitty Decke geklaut oder sowas und da musste man Papa auf der Arbeit anrufen dafür.
Und die haben ins Telefon geschrien, Alter, ich stand manchmal auf dem Gang und hab gehört, wenn er ans Telefon gegangen ist, das war schon geil.
Und das ist halt jemand, der ist gern auf die Arbeit gekommen, der ist echt gern auf die Arbeit gekommen, einfach weil er Ruhe hatte.
Klaut, was mach ich denn jetzt, oh mein Gott. Und, und der war immer super ruhig am Telefon, ja, aber du hast dem angemerkt, der ist froh, dass er nicht daheim sein muss.
Der hat sich gefreut, mittags ist er dann noch aufs Klo gegangen, hat eine Runde gepennt, das war schon so der Running Gag.
Bei uns war mittags teilweise aufs Klo gegangen, da hast du immer irgendwelche Leute schnarchen gehört.
Ich glaube, ich geh mal davon aus, dass er das gewesen ist, weil er war immer zum passenden Zeitpunkt nicht da.
Ja, und du hast so richtig, du hast so richtig gemerkt, für den ist das entspannend, dass er auf der Arbeit sein kann, ja.
Ansonsten war der immer super aufgeregt bei allem, aber wenn die Familie angerufen hatte, war er voll entspannt.
Die haben ihn dann ins Ohr geschrien und der hat dann gesagt, aha, das ist echt so, verstehe, ja.
Aber genau so hat sich das angehört, ey, genau.
Ich hab das echt gut nachgemacht, exakt so hat sich das angehört.
Wie machen wir das jetzt mit der Decke?
Ultra entspannend, ja, auf der Arbeit übelst hektisch bei allem.
Und dem hast du richtig angemerkt, alter, der will überhaupt nicht von daheim arbeiten.
Der ist froh, dass er auf die Arbeit kommen darf.
So Leute, gibt's natürlich auch, ja.
Also wenn man auf die Idee kommen sollte, irgendwie so alle Homeoffice, alle müssen.
Nee, nee, also vorschreiben für dich ist eine schlechte Idee.
Es gibt auch Leute, die wollen nicht.
Hallo, Jack.
Drittens, auch noch eine Sache, oder drittens, ich weiß gar nicht mal, wie viele Punkten ich schon bin.
Drittens oder viertens oder 69, keine Ahnung.
Oh, das war Cringe Talk, ey.
Es ist auch oftmals so ein bisschen ein offenes Geheimnis, dass manche es eher ruhig angehen lassen im Homeoffice.
Viele nutzen das auch inoffiziell so ein bisschen als Freizeit, auch mit dem Segen vom Chef.
Ja gut, das ist okay.
Das ist immer so ein bisschen die Frage, je nachdem, wie das in der jeweiligen Firma gehandhabt wird.
Ja, das ist ja nichts Schlimmes, das ist ja allgemein bekannt eigentlich.
Ein Beispiel sein, dass wenn die Leute zum Beispiel an enger Zeit gearbeitet haben, wo sie offiziell gar nicht arbeiten durften,
oder halt irgendwas hätten anmelden müssen, oder der Chef hat es verpennt, das Ganze anzumelden,
oder man hat gearbeitet, weil man nachts angerufen wurde, es war so blödes dran gegangen quasi,
und ist dann vor der Ablauf der Zeit wieder auf die Arbeit gekommen.
Also so Sachen, wo eigentlich der Mitarbeiter schon der Firma entgegengekommen ist,
dann sagen viele Chefs auch so nach dem Motto, weißt du was?
Ja, ich erzähl nix Schlimmes in dem Video, das passt schon alles.
... so nach dem Motto, das ist dann fast ausschließlich nicht auf offiziellen Wegen.
Ja, das passt schon, ich erzähl da.
Ich erzähl da nur so Dinge, da ist es schon okay, da passiert was.
Und selbst wenn da was will, ist dabei gewesen, wer hätte da nix gesagt.
Aber ich wollte nur noch mal kontrollieren, ob da irgendwas dabei ist, wo man sich drüber streiten kann.
Bei GitLab arbeiten fast nur im Homeoffice, okay, ja kann sein.
Aber Homeoffice ist wirklich eine sehr angenehme Geschichte.
Allerdings, Leute, ich hab jetzt zwei Wochen oder eineinhalb Wochen Urlaub.
Das heißt, morgen ist kein Homeoffice angesagt, sondern morgen ist Ausschlafen und Overwatch.
Also ich mach morgen ein Video zu dieser Overwatch-Worldcup-Geschichte.
Ich denke mal, das interessiert auch alle, die sich nicht für Overwatch interessieren,
weil es wieder so ein typischer Blizzard-Fail ist.
Und ich hab ja gestern mit euch schon gewettet im Stream um 20 Subs,
dass es nicht lange dauert, bis der erste Blizzard-Fan-Code ankommt.
Cod-Netcode-Analyse, oh ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt an im Video.
Die Modern Warfare Netcode-Analyse, die wollte ich mir heute schon angucken, hat aber bis jetzt noch keine Zeit.
Das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Frau sagt, Kinder klingen echt nach Folter.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, gut, vielleicht fehlt mir da die passende Frau dafür, möglich.
Aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Wir gehen Kinder im Zug schon immer so unglaublich auf den Keks.
Das ist echt Horror-Vorstellung, Kinder.
Fühlt schlecht, man.
Auf einem Peinlichkeits-Level wie Diablo Mobile, ja, anderweitig peinlich, weil sie viel zu knauserig sind.
Wenn die Kinder immer nervig sind.
Ja, ich glaube auch, es liegt ein bisschen daran, ob es die eigenen sind oder nicht.
Oh Leute, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt erzählen soll.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt im Stream machen soll.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt im Stream erzählen soll.
Ist mir nur gerade eingefallen.
Also.
Und zum Thema Kinder.
Und, und, dass ich mir das echt nicht vorstellen kann.
Ja, zumindest.
Ja, weil letztens, äh, weichen das jetzt ab.
Ich hab letztens den Fehler gemacht, deutschen Porn zu gucken.
Und auf einmal.
Sagt die Tussi im Video.
Sowas wie in der Richtung, oh ja, mach mich schwanger.
Da hab ich so instant, da hatte ich so instant den Steuerung W-Reflex.
Kennt ihr den Steuerung W-Reflex?
Das ist der Tab-Schließen-Reflex, äh.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich den Fehler gemacht hab, das auf Deutsch zu gucken.
Auf einmal sagt die Alte im Video echt irgendwas in der Richtung wie, ja, mach mich schwanger oder so.
Und da hab ich mir echt gedacht, Woodface, Alter.
Ich guck mir den Kram doch gerade an, dass sowas nicht passieren kann.
Alarm, Alarm, ja, ey, das war, das, das war nicht so schlimm wie Alarm, Alarm, ja.
Aber es war schon echt sehr merkwürdig, ja.
Und außerdem können irgendwie, irgendwie haben das Deutsche, egal was, mit Video produzieren und gescheiten Content produzieren einfach nicht drauf.
Und, also das hat mich, das hat mich echt geschockt.
Es ist egal, ob das auf YouTube ist oder eben auf Pornhub.
Oder eben auf Pornhub, es ist, deutscher Content ist einfach Müll.
Wie ist der, oh Gott Leute, ich wusste, dass ich's nicht hätte erzählen sollen, ne.
Wie schaust du das, eigene VM, äh, nur Linux-VM.
Also alles, was nicht normale Webseiten sind, wo ich, wo ich nicht so sicher bin, was drauf ist, immer Linux-VM mit Browser, immer.
Man weiß ja nie.
Aber ich mein, was denkt man sich als Produzentin, ich geh mal davon aus, dass dieses Video halt nur von der vor der Kamera produziert wurde, das war jetzt nicht nach irgendwie einer Profiproduktion aus.
Aber wie kommt man auf die Idee, dass irgendjemand, der auf dieser Seite ist und sich das Video anhört, diese Sätze in einem Video hören möchte?
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Gibt es wirklich Leute, die da, die da drauf stehen?
Ich kann's mir nicht vorstellen, ich kann mir das echt nicht vorstellen. Kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Drück mal ein Video zur Forschungszeit raus, ne. Ja, vergiss es.
Ja gut, auf der anderen Seite, egal, selbst das Abartigste, was du dir ausdenken kannst, sobald du es denken kannst, gibt es auf der Welt mindestens einen, der sich dran aufgeheilt.
Ist einfach so. Egal wie dumm und abartig es ist, du wirst mindestens einen finden, der es geil findet. Ist leider so.
Ist leider so.
So, und jetzt gucken wir Modern Warfare, Modern Warfare Z-Code-Analyse.
Ja, gibt es als ernsthaft?
Sind die Leute komplett von allen guten Geistern irgendwie verlassen? Na ja, was auch immer.
Es gibt auch Leute, die gucken sich auf diesen Seiten Katja Grasawitze Tittenleaks an oder sowas.
Wo ich mir auch denke, Leute, wie kann man sich so, na ja, was auch immer. Man weiß es nicht.
Wisst ihr, was das erste Video war, wo ich Katja Grasawitze gesehen habe? Kennt jemand noch Ben, Ben, wie hieß er, Ben Laksa oder so?
Der Tier, was war das? Der Tier Ernährungswissenschaftler Experte? Oder irgendwie, wie ging das? Der Teppich Verlegungsexperte oder sowas?
Kennt den Kram noch jemand? Warte mal, kennt das noch jemand? Ja, genau, der Typ. Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Hat er noch einen YouTube-Channel? Wo ist der YouTube-Channel von dem hin? Wo ist der YouTube-Channel?
Der ist weg. Genau, das ist das erste Video, wo die Träne mal aufgetaucht ist, was ich gesehen habe.
Danach habe ich mir nie wieder Videos von der angeguckt, weil das verstehe ich bis heute nicht, warum man sie sieht. Hat der sein Channel gelöscht? Warum findet man den nicht mehr?
Was? Wo müssen wir hin? Ja, genau das da.
Was ist mit dem Channel los? Der hat sein Channel? Wie umarmt dich dein Partner richtig? Es gibt How-To-Anleitungen, wie man sich umarmt.
Was ist mit dem Channel? Der hat sein Channel verkauft?
Jedoch wurden im September so wie alle seine Videos wieder verfügbar gemacht, noch ist aber nicht bekannt, ob persönlich diesen Kanal noch führt. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Der hat sein Channel verkauft?
Egal, ich fand die Videos eigentlich übelst lustig. Das war das erste Video, wo die Katja Grasawitze am Weg gelaufen ist, auf Videotechnik.
Ich hätte ja nie gedacht, dass die mal mehr Videos und Abos hat als Ben Luxor. Aber jetzt mal wieder zu seriöseren Sachen. Wir gucken uns jetzt die Modern Warfare Beta Netcode Analyse von BattleNonsense an.
Ich habe sogar heute Morgen irgendwann mal einen Kommentar reingepostet, so nach dem Motto, das Video hat mehr Aufruf. Es hat auch schon mehr, heute Morgen hat es nur 7000.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Deutscher, wenn ich das noch richtig zusammenbringe, deswegen habe ich das Kommentar auf Deutsch geschrieben und die Videos sind immer ziemlich gut. Nein, wir gucken jetzt keinen Asi-Ton.
Hi, my name is Chris and this is BattleNonsense. Today we will take a look at the Netcode of the Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2019 PC Beta.
As you surely know, most Call of Duty games use both dedicated game servers and listen servers, which many players falsely confuse with the P2P network.
Da hat er recht. Ich sage auch immer P2P, aber streng genommen stimmt das nicht. Es ist kein P2P, es ist, dass der Server auf einer Konsole läuft von jemand, der in der Lobby drin ist.
Die Lobby sind P2P und das VoIP ist P2P, aber das stimmt. Also Call of Duty Server sind nicht P2P in dem eigentlichen Sinne, die waren aber halt random oder keine Ahnung, nach welchen Bandbreiten Tests oder so, liefen die halt auf der Konsole des jeweiligen Lobby-Teilnehmers.
Es ist streng genommen nicht P2P, da hat er schon recht. Ujim abonniert Stufe 1, 3 Monate, Alter, big brain sub, hier IQ im Chat steigt mit extrem an.
Oh, ich hab noch was übersehen. Warum seh ich auf einmal so viele Subs? Jamal1791 und KetalaSubscribedPrime. Oh, hab ich das nicht gesehen. Kacknoob.
Oh, ihr seid noch da und hört das noch. Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs. Hast du vom Unfall von Gillette Abti mitbekommen? Nein.
Al-Kalf abonniert Stufe 1, 2 Monate. Pok. Speckhack. Ne, Speckhack. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Pok. xxfablusxx Twitch Prime.
Ich wusste nicht, dass Gillette Abti verunglückt ist. Nein, wusste ich nicht. Der ist jetzt im Rollstuhl ein Loch in der Bunge. Warum weißt du so was?
BattleTarzan666, NumberOfTheBeast, 2 Monate, Prime. So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber erstmal ein gutes Video an.
Muss man den kennen? Was, ihr kennt Gillette Abti nicht mehr? Das ist der, der alle rasiert. Äh. Eigentlich muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, fand ich das übelst unlustig.
Das hier war Gillette Abti. Das ist der Typ, der erzählt hat, dass er alle rasiert. Aber lustig fand ich es nie, aber das war vor 3, 4 Jahren, war das halt so ein bisschen wie vergleichbar.
Was gibt es denn heute? Das ist so ein bisschen wie Bruder muss los vor einer Weile. Bruder muss los. Oder das war halt vor 3, 4 Jahren, war das Gillette Abti. Oder was ist denn aktuell gerade so das Entsprechende? Das, was jeder sagt oder jeder sich anguckt.
Weiß nicht. Egal. Aber jetzt, wir gucken uns. Genau. Die Flair-Festnahme. Okay Leute, also jetzt hier. Ernsthaft. TechW, Alter. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken.
Die Analyse zum Netcode von Modern Warfare.
Da bloß nicht. Ja? Richtig. Richtig.
Hat er recht. Allerdings gibt es auf der Konsole immer noch keine Anzeige.
Das ist ja das erste, was wir auch festgestellt haben. Dass der Ping im Scoreboard richtig stimmt. Und der Ping im Scoreboard, den konnte man ja auch beeinflussen, indem man einfach die Tab-Taste hemmert.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass das hier oben halbwegs stimmt, aber wenn man sich das jetzt hier anguckt, ist die Latency in-game 11 Millisekunden und wenn er den Server pingt 27 Millisekunden.
Der Fairness halber muss man sagen, dass Ping-Latency nicht automatisch identisch sein muss mit UDP oder TCP-Latency. Aber in der Regel keine Abweichung um so viele, um 150%.
Das ist schlecht. Ja, das ist Fail. Das stimmt.
Alle anderen Games haben hier oben, zumindest Overwatch hat das, Battlefield hat das, so eine Anzeige, wenn es gerade Verbindungsprobleme gibt, dass es einfach mal hier kurz Verbindungs-Connection-Probleme aufblocken.
Das ist wichtig zu wissen in-game erstens, dass man vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen defensiv spielt oder wenn man gerade dabei bei dieser Anzeige gekillt wurde, dass man sich gar nicht großartig aufregen muss, sondern automatisch sagen kann, Alter, ah, es ist Connection.
Oder Packet Loss, wie auch ein Icon, das dir sagt, dass der Server ein Problem hat. Was das so frustrierend macht, ist, dass die Call of Duty WW2 Beta solche Icons hatten, aber diese verschwanden nach der Beta und kamen nicht in Black Ops 4 an.
Das stimmt. Ja, das ist in Overwatch übrigens auch super gemacht.
Das stimmt, das muss man DICE wirklich zugute halten. DICE ist in der Regel, was sowas angeht, relativ, relativ offen in der Kommunikation.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch am Anfang, was bei Battlefield 4 los war, wo sie dann mit ihrer komischen Action-Bubble-Geschichte angefangen haben und sowas.
Aber allein schon, dass man sowas in das Game einfügt, ist ein guter Hinweis darauf, dass man Wert darauf legt, dass es nichts zu verschleiern irgendwie so.
Warum droppt mein Twitch schon wieder Frames? Ich guck mal, vielleicht bin ich das.
Ach Leute, mal eine doofe Frage. Ist die Bitrate für euch eigentlich jetzt zu hoch, dass ihr das gucken könnt?
Weil ich kann die Bitrate ohne Probleme mal runter machen auf 4,5 oder so für Desktop-Übertragung.
Also ich hatte genug Leute, als ich vor zwei Jahren ab und zu mal dann noch mit VDSL Bitnestreams mit höherer Bitrate gemacht habe, dass ganz viele Leute gesagt haben, ach, ich kann den Stream nicht gucken.
Qualitätsoptionen. Ja, aber das Dumme ist, wenn man in Qualitätsoptionen runterschaltet, dann kann man nur auf 720 runterschalten und dann sieht der Desktop nicht mal scharf aus.
Da hat er Recht.
Äh Moment, was? Moment, das muss ich mir nochmal kurz zugeben. Was?
Äh Moment. Download, Upload. Moment, was gucke ich mir da gerade jetzt an?
Soll das Download Upload, soll das hier die Verzögerung sein? Ach nee, Datenrate ist das.
Ah ok, Kilobytes. 64,62 Hertz? Was ist denn eine Tickrate von 62, das ist doch voll Schäpp irgendwie.
Moment, was? Eine Tickrate von 21, 21? Deswegen hat sich Ground War auch so scheiße angefühlt an manchen Stellen.
Das ergibt tatsächlich Sinn. Ok, ja gut, dass das Game nicht viel Bandbreite braucht, ist uns allen bewusst denke ich mal. Das ist das, was ich auch immer sage, dass Spiele im Endeffekt keine Bandbreite brauchen.
Oder so gut wie keine Bandbreite. Also das kann man wirklich mit jedem noch so großen Kackanschluss, der ist light außen vor gelassen für Battlefield, aber das kann man in jedem Anschluss spielen.
Ja, das haben wir auch festgestellt, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern? Als ich versucht habe Call of Duty zu starten und Virtual Studio im Hintergrund anhatte, das ging nicht.
Und ich dachte mir damals schon, dass es irgendeine Anti-Cheat-Maßnahme, der Virtual Studio im Hintergrund laufen hat, muss böse Hexor sein. Und da ist anscheinend was dran.
Und da ist anscheinend was dran. Was ist der Hexor? Ok. Das ist doch ok.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung. Das stimmt, logisch.
Deswegen hat sich Ground War auch so scheiße angefühlt im Vergleich zu den normalen Spielmodi.
Hat sich übelst freudig angefühlt wie die Hit-Track und wie schnell du teilweise gestorben bist, ohne zu reagieren und sowas. Das wird es erklären in Ground War.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
150? Ich bilde mir ein, dass Overwatch ab 150... Ach Moment, das ist kein 150ms Delay zum Server. Das ist alles zusammen.
Also alle möglichen Geschichten, was das Spiel intern interpoliert, was du für einen Eingabe-Lag hast. Also quasi alles zusammen. Aber 150ms sind trotzdem ganz schön viel.
Das ist echt ganz schön viel. Ich würde mal sagen, Battlefield hat die Hälfte.
Es ist einfach nur aus dem Bauch aus. Ich habe keine Werte, aber ich denke, das kommt gleich noch.
Das ist kein ping, das ist nicht gleich. Alter, ist das mies.
Ja, Overwatch. Ich sage euch, 1 macht Overwatch wirklich gut.
Also die ganze Netzwerkgeschichte, man kann von Overwatch halten, was man will, aber die Netzwerkgeschichte ist wirklich ziemlich gut. Es gibt so viel, was an Overwatch aufregt und so viel, was an Overwatch abfuckt, aber ganz ehrlich,
anteilmäßig, überlegt euch mal, wie viel rum genervt wird von Spielern bei Call of Duty und am Anfang auch von Battlefield, was irgendwelche Netcode-Geschichten angeht.
Und überlegt euch mal, wie selten das Ganze in Overwatch passiert. In Overwatch wissen die Leute, dass es an anderen Dingern liegt als an der Verbindung.
Also netzwerktechnisch ist Overwatch jetzt wirklich ohne Mist. Das beste Game, was ich netzwerktechnisch je gespielt habe. Das Game hat andere Probleme. Aber netzwerktechnisch ist Overwatch wirklich eines der besten Games, die je gemacht wurden.
Was kann man dann dagegen machen? Gar nichts. Das wie gut Fortnite ist. Du kannst ja gar nichts dagegen machen. Das ist ja nicht dein Ping.
Dein Ping ist das hier. Das ist alles, was im Spiel sich aufstaut und quasi die gemessene Verzögerung von Schießen zu du siehst, dass geschossen wurde. Du siehst, dass es Wirkung erzielt.
Das ist quasi das Delay zwischen Ursache und Wirkung. Movement passiert. Du siehst Movement beim Gegner. Und das ist ganz schön viel. In 120 Millisekunden hat sich ein Gegner schon halb rum gedreht, wenn er schnell ist.
Wie misst er die Angaben? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich gehe mal davon aus, mit zwei Accounts und zwei Rechner, die nebeneinander stehen. Denk mal, der wird sich einfach selbst zugucken.
Der weiß ja, wann er sich bewegt und der sieht es auf dem anderen Bildschirm. Ich denke mal, dass er es einfach mit zwei Rechner und zwei Bildschirmen nebeneinander machen wird. Und dann entweder eine Kamera auf dem Bildschirm mit Timer oder irgendwie anders.
Der hat noch ein Video, wo er seinen Tester dabei klärt. Aber ich denke mal, dass es so ähnlich sein wird.
Ja, aber du selbst stirbst instant. Richtig. Richtig. Das ist auch im Prinzip ganz logisch, weil du gleichzeitig relativ gut das Ganze updaten kannst.
Ich meine, du weißt, wann du deine Maus gedrückt hast. Dein Gameclient weiß, ob du über einem Gegner warst. Ob die Hitmarker wirklich Server gesüngt sind, weiß ich gar nicht.
Vielleicht sind die Hitmarker auch so eine Geschichte. Dein Client denkt, dass er getroffen hat. Er zeigt mal eine Hitmarker, ob es wirklich ein Hit gewesen ist oder so. Stellt sich dann ein paar Millisekunden später raus, weiß ich nicht.
Aber, dass man seine eigenen Sachen responsive anfühlt, das würde ich ihm auch recht geben. Das ist nicht so schwierig. Dein Client weiß, wann du die Maus gedrückt hast, kann das alles rendern und anzeigen, ist kein Problem.
Wenn du allerdings jetzt derjenige bist, der beschossen wird oder wenn du den Gegner anguckst und der Gegner bewegt sich, dann sieht das natürlich wieder ganz anders aus.
Weil dann hat dein Client erst wirklich die Informationen, sobald er sie kriegt.
Aber 150 Millisekunden, what the fuck. Das ist dreimal so lang wie in Overwatch. Drei bis viermal so lang wie in Overwatch, Alter.
150 Millisekunden, wisst ihr was in 150 Millisekunden passiert ist? Ein 150 Millisekunden hat sich den Gegner fast umgedreht und euch einen Headshot verpasst.
Das ist jetzt natürlich übertrieben. Aber zumindest hat sich in 150 Millisekunden ein Gegner umgedreht.
Dann kommen nochmal 150 Millisekunden dazu, dass er es kapiert. Ihr beschießt ein Gegner, 150 Millisekunden bis er reagiert, 150 Millisekunden, einmal die Maus rumgedreht.
Oder ein bisschen länger, aber es ist unglaublich viel. Nein, Reaktionszeit sind so 120-150 Millisekunden. Also 50 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit hat keiner. 1000 Millisekunden sind eine Sekunde. Aber das ist ultra viel.
Das verstehe ich auch bei Call of Duty nicht. Die machen aus allem so ein Geheimnis. Warum machen die das nicht wie in Overwatch, dass du in-game, dass du Netzwerk-Performance, dass du eine Performance-Craft hast, sowohl für die Game-Performance lokal bei dir als über die Netzwerk-Performance,
über Pakete, die verloren gehen, über zu hohe Latency oder quasi deine Schüsse nicht mehr registrieren. Overwatch zeigt dir das alles an, wenn du willst. Und das verstehe ich halt nicht. Warum versteckt man das?
Es gibt doch eigentlich nur einen Grund das Ganze zu verstecken und das ist, man weiß, dass es Mist ist, aber man möchte nicht, dass es so viele Leute rauskriegen, dass es Mist ist. Ach ja und keine Patch-Nots sind auch dumm, das stimmt.
Die geben halt einen Fick auf PC-Spieler, das hat auch mit PC-Spieler nichts zu tun. Das betrifft alle. Und ganz ehrlich, auch ein Playstation-Spieler möchte wissen, was er für eine Verbindung hat. Das ist überhaupt kein PC-exklusives Problem.
Ich würde ja gerne ein Video mit dem aufnehmen. Der ist deutschsprachig, relativ sicher. Ich würde gerne ein Video mit dem aufnehmen, ich habe mir ein bisschen über Netzwerk-Geschichten ausgelassen, auch Call of Duty-technisch.
Und damit, aufgrund der vorherigen Call of Duty-Games und meiner Erfahrung in der Beta, erwarte ich, dass dieses Spiel die Erfahrung des Schütters auch sehr gefällt, wenn ich den Lack-Kompensation testen werde, nach dem Release.
Ich freue mich wirklich auf die letzte Version dieses Spiels. Nicht nur, um zu sehen, ob die Entwickler einige Probleme fixiert haben, die ich bemerkt habe, aber auch, weil ich die Beta sehr viel genossen habe.
V.a. die Waffen und die Bewegungen fühlten sich gut an. Der Zeitpunkt, um zu töten, könnte ein bisschen schneller sein, aber das ist nur ich.
Und das ist es für heute. Einen großen Schuss an meine Patreons, denn ihre Unterstützung ermöglicht mir, Videos wie diese zu kreieren.
Wenn ihr meinen Content genießt und diese tollen Leute, die mich unterstützen, gerne mitbekommen, dann findet ihr den Link auf meiner Patreon-Page in der Beschreibung unten unten.
Dort findet ihr auch Links zu meinen Social-Accounts, in Bezug auf die Videos, auf denen ich arbeite.
Das war nie Peer-to-Peer, das stimmt schon.
Vibe ist Peer-to-Peer, aber Vibe ist in der Regel immer, sonst ist es halt doof.
Voice-Chat ist halt so eine Geschichte, die entweder schnell und direkt ist oder gar nicht, weil es bringt dir bei Voice-Chat nichts.
Wenn du Pakete hast, die teilweise in der falschen Reihenfolge ankommen, bringt dir nichts, wenn du ein Paket bekommst, das vorher abgespielt werden müsste, danach.
Wenn Vibe nicht prioritisiert ist und Vibe nicht möglichst schnell ankommt, dann funktioniert Vibe nicht richtig.
Aber das Recht, Call of Duty war noch nie Peer-to-Peer. Ich sag mal Vibe außen vor und das Lobby-System natürlich auch.
Richtig gutes Video, gefällt mir. Video hat mir echt gut gefallen. Was haben wir sonst noch für Videos in letzter Zeit gemacht?
40% less input lag without AMD und Anti-Lag und das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an.
Bufferploat, da bin ich immer skeptisch bei solchen Videos.
Weil ich bin ja eigentlich verfecht davon, dass 99% der Leute, die dieses Wort Bufferploat aufgeschnappt haben
und jetzt meinen, ihre Verbindung oder ihre Gaming-Performance hätte irgendwas mit Bufferploat zu tun, viel höher ist, als dass es wirklich damit Probleme gibt.
Was heißt das eigentlich? Das ist ein bisschen schwammig.
In der Regel könnte man sagen, dass du einfach, wenn du viele Pakete hast, mehr Pakete in deinen Router quasi reingehen, als der verschicken kann.
Also quasi wenn du mehr Pakete hast oder wenn du ähnlich viele Pakete hast wie dein Upload, da müssen die Dinge ja irgendwo in deinem Router gespeichert werden.
Irgendwann werden sie verworfen. Und wenn du jetzt viele Pakete hast, die unterschiedlich groß sind, unterschiedlich priorisiert sind,
oder nicht unterschiedlich priorisiert sind, unterschiedlich groß sind und theoretisch unterschiedlich wichtig sind,
dann hast du das Problem, dass die quasi um deinen Upload konkurrieren.
Und die hängen halt in irgendeinem Buffer rum.
So und die Sache ist bloß die, die meisten Leute haben damit kein Problem, weil so richtig tritt das Ganze natürlich nur auf,
wenn du deine Leitung auslastest ordentlich während du spielst. Macht kaum einer.
Das einfachste gegen Bufferpload ist, einfach nicht 20 Sachen zu machen, während man spielt.
Ist das ein Problem für Streamer? Ja, theoretisch schon, wenn du nicht so einen hohen Upload hast.
Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel nur einen 5mbit Upload hast, du streamst mit 4,5mbit und spielst, dann hast du da tatsächlich Probleme.
Also hat man quasi Bufferpload, wenn der Upload-Speed das Bottle legt. Und das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich weiß, da gehört noch viel, viel mehr dabei. Es gibt auch zig Q-Algorithmen.
Ich muss euch aber ehrlich sagen, im Detail, was es da mittlerweile alle Veranstellungen gibt.
Ich hab letztes Mal geguckt, auch für meinen Mikrotik-Router gibt es die abgedrehtesten Q-Einstellungen.
Für OpenWrt gibt es die abgedrehtesten Q-Einstellungen, wo du halt gucken kannst, dass die wichtigen, im Prinzip geht es einfach immer nur darum,
dass die wichtigen Pakete zuerst rausgeschickt werden. Das ist bei allen Sachen so.
Also es geht im Prinzip immer darum, dass die wichtigen Pakete zuerst rauskommen.
Aber in der Regel kannst du Bufferpload damit zusammenfassen, dass einfach Pakete in irgendwelche Netzwerkgeräten länger zwischengespeichert werden, als sie sollten.
Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nochmal an hier. Hat das jemand schon mal probiert? Nvidia Ultra Low Latency und Anti-Lag?
Ich hab's mal eingeschaltet, weiß nicht mehr in welchem Game das war und da hat es... Was war denn das für ein Game?
Das könnte sogar Overwatch gewesen sein, wo ich mal die Role-Q probiert hab.
Ich hatte es in Overwatch eingeschaltet und irgendwie hat es sich ganz merkwürdig angefühlt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich an zu viel Lag gewöhnt war, aber es hat sich irgendwie komisch angefühlt.
Und deswegen hab ich es wieder ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt muss Jasper übelst.
Welchen Roborock hast du und kannst du empfehlen?
Custom Firm, ja ich hab einen Roborock S50 und ich kann Custom Firm werden.
Aber was, wenn du einfach nicht auf deinem PC gehen kannst, um Spiele mit höheren Framestand zu spielen?
Um den Inputlag zu reduzieren in solchen Situationen, gibt AMD ein Featuren namens Anti-Lag
und Nvidia gibt einen Ultra-Low-Latency-Mode.
Also schauen wir uns mal an, was AMD über Anti-Lag sagt.
Es hilft, den Inputlag zu reduzieren in GPU-limitierten Fällen.
Und es kann den Inputlag bei fast einem vollen Framestand schrinken.
Das bedeutet, wenn ein Spiel 60FPS läuft, kann Anti-Lag den Inputlag von 16ms reduzieren.
Bei 120FPS sind es ca. 8ms und so weiter.
Anti-Lag braucht zumindest einen HD7700-Grafikkart und funktioniert in Spielen, die DIRKT-X11 oder DIRKT-X9 benutzen.
Jedoch, um Anti-Lag in DIRKT-X9 zu benutzen, braucht man zumindest einen RX5700.
Jetzt schauen wir uns mal an, was Nvidia über ihre Low-Latency-Modes sagt.
Wie viele von euch wissen, hat Nvidia ein Maximum-Pre-Rendered-Frames-Setting in der Kontrollpanel für über eine Dezember.
Das erlaubte den Spielern, wie viele Frames in der Render-Cube abgebuffert werden.
Hier ist es wichtig zu wissen, dass ein kleiner Buffer weniger Verlagerung bedeutet.
In dem aktuellen Fahrzeug wurde dieses Featuren zu Low-Latency genannt.
Off bedeutet, dass der Spiel-Engine entscheidet, wie viele Frames abgebuffert werden.
On bedeutet, dass die Zahl von Frames bis zu 1 abgebuffert wird.
Und Ultra bedeutet, dass die Frames nur in der Zeit sind, um die Grafikkarte abzubilden und zu renderen.
Just like Anti-Lag, die Low-Latency-Modes haben den größten Impakt, wenn ihr Spiel GPU-baut.
Also, wenn euer Grafikkart ausgelöst wird.
Es funktioniert auch nur mit Spielen, die DIRKT-X9 oder DIRKT-X11 benutzen.
Aber es ist nicht limited, wenn euer Grafikkart ausgelöst wird.
In philoso neighborhood – Anti-Lag ist brewer infiltrativ.
Ich bin nochNotice.
Die Verwendung des Anti-Lag ist mehr komfortabel,
denn man kann es innerhalb des Overlays,
das man mit der Shortcut ALT und R bringen kann,
während man nur zwischen den Lade-Modes
im Nvidia-Kontroll-Panel wechseln kann.
Das sind übrigens so Sachen, die verstehe ich nicht. Die haben doch seit Ewigkeiten, hat Nvidia hier dieses komische Overlay.
Das Shadowplay-Overlay, haben die ja schon ewig drinnen.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum man nicht wichtige Grafik-Settings wie sowas zum Beispiel in das Shadowplay-Overlay macht.
Das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Das ist ja nicht das Einzige.
Man könnte Helligkeit unabhängig vom Spiel einstellen.
Man könnte Anti-Alasing-Mode beispielsweise einstellen.
Warum ist das nicht im Overlay einfach mit drinnen? Das wäre doch viel cooler.
Und Nvidias Ultra-Low-Latency-Mode sind geplant, Input-Lag zu reduzieren, wenn deine Grafik-Karte komplett ausgelöst ist.
Aber wie weißt du, ob das der Fall ist?
Um den GPU-Lang zu checken, kannst du einfach MSI Afterburner installieren,
welches eine vollkustomisierte In-Game-Overlay gibt.
In diesem Beispiel hier kannst du sehen, dass meine Grafik-Karte komplett ausgelöst ist.
Und so ist mein Frame-Rate von der Leistung meines Grafik-Kartes limited.
Das ist eine Situation, wo beide Anti-Lag und Ultra-Low-Latency-Mode die Input-Lag weiter reduzieren.
Und so macht das Spiel mehr responsiv.
Wenn du weniger als 99% sehen würdest, dann bist du nicht nur von der Leistung deines Grafik-Kartes limited.
Und so werden weder Anti-Lag noch Ultra-Low-Latency-Mode helfen.
Das kann sein, wenn V-Sync deinen Frame-Rate bei der Refrigeration des Monitors lockt.
Oder wenn du einen FPS-Limiter benutzt, um stabilere Frametime zu erreichen.
Oder um den Frame-Rate in der variablen Refrigeration von deinem Free-Sync oder Cheap-Sync-Monitor zu halten.
Aber es ist auch möglich, dass du CPU-limitiert bist.
Das bedeutet, dass dein CPU so langsam ist, dass es dein System zerschlägt.
Und so kann die Grafik-Karte ihr voller Potenzial entfalten.
Ich will nicht zu tief in das Thema in heute's Video gehen.
Aber bitte weiss, dass wenn du einen CPU mit vier oder mehr Cores hast,
dann die kombinierte CPU-Utilisierung von allen Cores nichts zu erzählen.
Um herauszufinden, ob du CPU-Limitiert bist, musst du auf den CPU-Load von jedem individuen Auge schauen.
Das wäre ein relativ einfaches und einfaches Test, das nur ein paar Stunden dauern sollte.
Aber wenig wusste ich, als diese Tests etwas gezeigt haben, das, in meiner Meinung nach,
viel interessanter und vielleicht sogar mehr wichtig ist als diese Features.
Aber zuerst, wie teste ich, wie responsiv ein Spiel fühlt sich an?
Was ich interessiert, ist das Ende-zu-Ende-Delay, das jeder Spieler betrifft.
Das bedeutet, dass der Delay zwischen dem End- und Ende-Delay,
wie den linken Knopf-Knopf-Knopf zu drücken,
und der Schussfeuer auf dem Monitor zu zeigen.
Um diesen Knopf zu messen, benutze ich eine High-Speed-Kamera
und eine Gaming-Maus, die mit einem LED direkt zu dem Schuss des linken Knopf-Knopfs kommt.
Dann stelle ich die High-Speed-Kamera auf den Monitor
und schreibe, was passiert, wenn ich den linken Knopf-Knopf drücke.
Während der hohe Geschwindigkeit wird geschaut,
schaue ich dann für den Schuss, in dem der LED ansteht,
und dann zähle ich die Schüsse, bis ich den Schuss des Inputs sehe.
Das gibt mir einen Delay zwischen dem End- und Ende-Delay.
Das ist echt eine clevere Idee.
Also, die Ergebnisse, die ich euch zeigen werde,
sind die Delay, die ihr mit dem Hardware spielen könnt.
Für meine ersten Tests benutze ich Overwatch bei 1080p, 144Hz,
mit dem Epic-Grafik-Preset und einer Render-Resolution von 200%
um ein bisschen Stress auf den RX 5700 und den GTX 1080.
Ich habe auch die Reduzierung des Buffering-Settings in Overwatch
bemerkt, dass es nicht mit Anti-Lag und dem Ultra-Low-Latency-Mode interviert.
So, mit dem Graphik-Kart komplett auf 99% maximiert,
hat Overwatch 85FPS auf dem RX 5700 und 81FPS auf dem GTX 1080.
Unter diesen Bedingungen habe ich einen Durchschnitt von 71,33ms auf dem RX 5700 und 72ms auf dem GTX 1080.
Dann habe ich Anti-Lag auf dem RX 5700, das den Durchschnitt von 9ms auf dem GTX 1080 reduziert.
Das ist ein bisschen weniger als 1FPS auf 84FPS.
Ja gut, ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich das auswirkt, wenn er das mit mehr FPS macht,
weil das sind ja FPS, da würde ich eh nichts spielen.
Mal gucken, es müsste ja dann eigentlich noch größer werden.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass das
also umso weniger, ich hätte jetzt eher damit gerechnet, dass das Input-Lag höher wird, wenn die Frames runtergehen.
Which then reduced the input lag even further.
Compared to the first test, I now measured 30ms less input lag.
That's a reduction of 42% compared to running the game at 99% GPU utilization without Anti-Lag.
And that's despite the fact that the game now ran at 60 instead of 85FPS.
Then I ran the same test with the GTX 1080 and low latency.
Which showed the exact same behavior.
So what you can see here is that when your graphics card is completely maxed out,
both Anti-Lag and ultra-low latency will slightly reduce the input lag as advertised.
However, if you just ensure that your GPU does not run at 99% load,
then you can reduce the input lag significantly, much more than both Anti-Lag and ultra-low latency.
However, you reduce your frame rate in the process, which can cause that games look less smooth.
Also, when you are not GPU limited, like when you use an FPS limiter and then enable Anti-Lag or ultra-low latency,
then they can cause an input lag increase, as you can see when you compare the results of these tests here.
Now, I don't blame you if you don't believe these results, because I did not believe them at first either.
So, I repeated them many times to be sure that they are accurate.
I also did a few additional tests with weaker graphics cards, like a GTX 1050 and RX 580.
I ran the tests with a render scale of 100% and with different graphics settings.
But throughout all these tests, I was really interested in what it would look like in Overwatch,
with, let's say, 200 plus FPS and low settings. It could also be post-processing.
All these tests, the input lag still increased significantly as soon as the GPU hit a load of 99%.
So at this point I was more interested in that than the Anti-Lag feature and the ultra-low latency mode,
as my tests already confirmed that these work as advertised.
Then I tried to find out at which GPU load that input lag increase occurs exactly.
So I set the frame rate limiter to 78 inside Overwatch, which kept the GPU load below 98%.
In that scenario I still measured slightly more delay compared to when I had the frame rate limit set to 60,
but it was still significantly lower than when the graphics card was maxed out.
Then I tried to find out if that also happens at higher frame rates.
At this point I decided to continue testing just with the GTX 1080 as I had that installed in the PC
and it was clear to me that this behaviour is neither AMD nor Nvidia specific.
So I reduced the render scale to 150% which brought the frame rate up to 145.
At a GPU load of 99% I then measured an average button to pixel delay of 48.2ms.
When I then set the frame rate limiter inside Overwatch to 138 the GPU load dropped to less than 95%
and the input lag decreased by 14ms or 2 frames at 138 frames per second.
Now I had to find out if that is an Overwatch issue.
So I ran the same tests again in PUBG.
At 100FPS and a GPU load of 99% I measured an average button to pixel delay of 43.27ms.
With the built-in FPS limiter set to 90 the GPU load dropped to less than 95%
and I measured 11ms less input delay despite the game now running at a lower frame rate.
Then I switched over to Battlefield V.
At 99% GPU load and 84FPS I measured an average input delay of 65.2ms.
With the built-in frame rate limiter set to 79 and the GPU load at less than 97%
the input delay dropped by 22ms despite the lower frame rate.
I then also did a test with Battlefield V's future frame rendering feature disabled
which on its own caused the frame rate to drop to 72FPS and the GPU load to stay below 82%.
That reduced the input delay by about 6ms
which means that future frame rendering provides a similar input lag reduction as anti-lag and the ultra-low latency mode.
Earlier this week I sent my results to my contacts at AMD and Nvidia
so they know about my findings that reducing the GPU load leads to a significant input lag decrease.
I will let you know if I hear back from them about what causes this and if something can be done about that.
So now it's time to draw a conclusion.
Ich würde es echt mal in den Spielen mit low graphics settings interessieren.
Vielleicht ist es wirklich irgendein Post-Processing Crap
der bei Epic und Ultra-Settings mit dabei ist.
So, should you use these features?
Well, when your graphics card is completely maxed out then both features help and won't do any harm.
But make sure that you are actually GPU bound as these features can otherwise have a negative impact on the input lag as I have shown.
So, if you want to reduce the input lag while running games at an uncapped frame rate then I encourage you to give them a try.
However, you should also consider that your gaming experience isn't just about the maximum peak frame rate that your PC can achieve.
In the use case where anti-lag and the ultra-low latency mode are effective
you do not only face an unstable frame rate.
You also have to deal with inconsistent frame times.
Which means that the input lag that you are subjected to is constantly changing
as the frame rate will go up and down depending on what is happening in the game that you are playing.
If you are interested in a smooth gaming experience where you always have the same amount of input lag
which is important to build up muscle memory in competitive games
then you must limit your frame rate to a value that your PC can always maintain.
So, if that sounds interesting to you then I highly recommend that you watch the video that I made about that topic a while ago
where I show you how to get perfectly stable frame times and so consistent input lag.
Which also comes with the additional bonus that your graphics card won't be maxed out all the time
which means less noise, less heat and as we now know less input lag.
You can find a link to that video in the description down below.
And that's all for today. Big shout out to my Patreons as deal support.
In dem wünsche ich gern was aufnehmen. Einfach ein bisschen Netzwerkrahmen erzählen zu Games.
Ah fuck, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Mein Mikrofon spackt. Das spackt nix.
Habt ihr das diese Woche noch? Keine Ahnung, ich habe noch nicht mal gefragt.
Echt, aber es war wirklich ein sehr interessantes Video, muss ich sagen.
Was, ich bin abgeschnitten? Warum das denn?
Wie kann das sein, dass ich abgeschnitten bin? Fake News, glaube ich nicht.
Ach ja, ich weiß warum. Wackelkontakt, jetzt geht's wieder.
Ja ja, ich habe meinen Mute Button bewegt. Ich habe da eine Mikrofonverlängerung
mit einem Button drauf, den ich drücken kann, wenn ich mich muten will.
Und der ist halt, der ist halt, keine Ahnung, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 25 Jahre alt oder so, dieser Mute Button.
Dieses Ding hier, dieses Ding hier, ist das. Hier, guckt euch mal das Video an.
Dieses Teil, das ist der Mute Button, den verwende ich. Und das ist halt uralt, das ist halt uralt das Ding.
Ich verwende das eigentlich nur zum Muten, dass ich einen Button habe, wenn ich mal schnell muten muss.
Das war Release, keine Ahnung, 1998 oder so.
Guck mal, vor wann das ist. Und der hat halt ein bisschen, der hat halt ein bisschen Wackelkontakt.
Es gibt dazu noch nicht mal Reviews.
Ja, das hatte so eine billige Voice-Erkennung damals dabei. Das ist, das ist keine Ahnung, das ist von 98 rum oder so.
Building a PC using only Wish. Haben wir nicht letztens ein Video geguckt?
Wish.com, wo einer mit der Grafikkarte skirmast wurde.
Hat dich dein Chef auch auf Twitch schon gefollowed? Ich weiß nicht.
Der hat aber anderes zu tun, als Livestream zu gucken. Der ist mit seiner Family beschäftigt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der im Livestream ist. So Video gucken, kann er, kann er, ist ja was anderes.
Würde mich interessieren, wie mein Schreibtisch. Oh, das willst du nicht sehen.
Da liegt ganz viel, ganz viel Papierkram rum. Es liegen Jumperkabel rum.
Es liegen Ladegeräte rum. USB-Sticks liegen rum. Controller liegen rum.
Das sieht übelst, übelst dritte Welt aus, mein Schreibtisch.
Ist sie nicht niedlich?
Irgendwie, irgendwie guckt sie so ein bisschen vorwurfsvoll.
Sie fragt im Motto, warum hast du mir keine Knusper-Ecken gegeben?
Sie guckt so streng. Sie fragt im Motto, wie sieht es aus? Wann gibt es Knusper-Ecken?
Guck mal, guck mal, ich mache schon deinen komischen Scheiß hier mit. Jetzt gib endlich was.
Das ist nicht KatzFPS. Also original KatzFPS war ja das.
So quasi MautsFPS war das und die hat noch keinen FPS-Namen.
Übrigens übelst Fail benannt. Also sie heißt Chico, weil sie eigentlich eher Chica heißen müsste.
Weil es ist ja eine Mädchen. Chico passt irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Aber was auch immer, sie reagiert drauf, wenn man Chico sagt.
Ich finde es eh lustig, mit seinen Katzen reden, wenn er immer so blöd.
Chico, Chico, Chico, auch richtig dumm ey. Chico, Chico, ja fein ist Chico.
Richtig doof, ja. So wie der letzte Pepega.
Ich rede so mit Menschen, dass Ratchet, ja gut, mach es. Bei manchen sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Kannst du ein Ding hier zumachen?
Noch Jobanzeigen von gestern auf.
Es ist 2019, wieso kann sie nicht Chico heißen? Stimmt. Heute ist alles möglich.
Wish PC Build gucken. Nee Leute, das gucken wir am Sonntag.
Ich schreibe es mir extra auf. Das gucken wir am Sonntag.
Wir machen Sonntag und wir machen heute keinen vorgezogenen Reaction Stream.
Wir machen den wöchentlichen Reaction Content gibt es sonntags morgens im Aufwachstream, wie immer.
Nicht heute. Heute wird nicht Reacted.
Lass das nicht dein Chef sehen, warum? Ich suche ja auch nichts Neues, ich gucke einfach nur, was es gibt.
Leute, eins ist echt so, wenn 1999 einer gesagt hätte, dass wir 2019 mehr Gips verwenden als jemals zuvor, der hätte mich ausgelacht.
1999 war Gips so ein Format, wo man gesagt hat, ey, das verwendet eigentlich keiner mehr, nur noch, wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Und seit 5, 6 Jahren oder so sind Gips wieder voll angesagt.
Guck mal, ich soll Tio folgen.
Was macht denn der Tio so?
Tio spielt WoW Classic.
Tja, habt ihr noch irgendwelche Fragen oder so? Ich habe keine Ideen mehr gerade, was ich noch machen soll, weil ich bin übelst kaputt von dieser ganzen Schulungsgeschichte und da ich wieder seit heute Morgen schon unterwegs bin.
Ich habe noch irgendwas wichtiges was verklärt müssen. Was wurde aus dem Fiverr Code ist fertig. Die Fiverr Code Geschichte ist durch.
10 von 11 haben abgesagt und einer hat was geliefert, was nicht richtig funktioniert.
Big Brain, indische Programmierer halt.
Wollen wir uns das anschauen?
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade so aus dem Bauch raus sagen am Wochenende, aber ich glaube am Wochenende kriege ich das nicht hin.
Weil ich muss noch das Fazit Video, der andere Serial hat mich gefragt, ob wir nicht zusammen was aufnehmen wollen. Habe ich ewig nichts gemacht, ist es aber auch nicht, dass wir so ultra dicke gewesen sind oder so.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall ein Fazit Video zu Modern Warfare aufnehmen. Ich muss zu Modern Warfare die Geschichte aufnehmen. Die ganze Lootbox und Exklusivitätsgeschichte. Das zum Overwatch World Cup. Ich glaube da komme ich nicht dazu am Wochenende noch das Fiverr Video zu machen.
Oder ich komme schon dazu, aber ich kann es nicht hochladen, weil das sind dann zu viele Videos. Wann kommt nächstes Video morgen? Wo ich Blizzard ein bisschen flame wegen ihrer komischen BlizzCon Praktiken.
Hättest du Bock mit dem Commander Krieger ein Video zu machen? Wenn es ein gutes Thema gibt, warum nicht? Aber mir fällt da gerade keins ein. Mir fällt da gerade nichts ein, was wir zusammen machen können.
In welcher Sprache sollten die Fiverr unterschreiben, C-Sharp?
Also ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich mache Videos alle zwei bis drei Tage. Wenn ich viel zu tun habe, drei Tage, so wie jetzt diese Woche. Ansonsten alle zwei Tage. Und aktuell gehen mir die Themen auch nicht aus.
Die Belius fragt, ich habe ein Informatikstudium angefangen. Warte mal kurz.
Ich habe eine Informatikstudium angefangen, aber noch keine Vorahnung in Sachen Programmieren. Wir lernen im ersten Semester C++. Unser Professor hat uns von Visual Studio als IDE für Anfänger abgeraten, da es wohl zu schwer für den Anfänger ist.
Visual Studio ist eigentlich ganz gut. Wie stehst du dazu? Später brauchen wir das wohl eh und ich will mich an nichts anderes gewöhnen, nur um mich dann umzugewöhnen. Visual Studio ist keine schlechte IDE.
Und so kompliziert ist Visual Studio ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Ich persönlich finde den Cute Creator am besten für C und C++, wenn es einfach darum geht, dass man was braucht, was tut. Der Cute Creator ist wirklich nice.
Das Ding heißt wirklich so. Aber wenn ihr später Visual Studio braucht, gibt es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund, warum du nicht einfach mit Visual Studio anfangen solltest.
Der Cute Creator ist relativ simpel. Er hat alles dabei, was man braucht.
Für mich ist der Cute Creator wirklich zum Einstieg, somit das beste, was man an IDE verwenden kann, C++.
Ist deutlich simpler als Visual Studio, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr später Visual Studio braucht und Sachen unter Windows macht, nehmt von Anfang an Visual Studio. Ist das einfachste.
Ich mache gerade mal ein Upgrade, kann ich schaden in der Zwischenzeit, wo wir hier schwätzen.
Wow, ja ja, Updates, easy Updates, easy Live. Gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subs und Follower gesehen habe. Nein, der letzte war der Roffle1436. Neues Twitch Design MonkaS.
Ja, die Farben sind ein bisschen merkwürdig. Die Schrift ist auch erstmal gewöhnungsbedürftig. Wir wissen jetzt ja, dass die Schrift Robert heißt, wir haben ja nachgeguckt.
Was, Bits? Bits habe ich übersehen. Wo sehe ich Bits überhaupt? Oh, das Ratchet, 500 Bits, 5 Euro, Poggers. Wahnsinn, wenn du schon keine Option für Donations hast.
Von den 5 Euro hättest du aber auch Subscriber machen können. Dann hättest du wenigstens, ähm, Emotes.
Auf 5 Abos geschenkt. Oha, krasser Scheiß. Aber du hast doch selbst gar kein Abo.
Das ist Big Brain. Verschenkst Subs und bist selbst kein Sub. Jetzt ist er auch Sub. G-Baded, ja.
Also für den Sub und für die 5 gegifteten Subs. ZClaros, 2 Monate auch am Start, nice.
Das ist cool. Oh, ich hoffe nicht, dass wir schon wieder die nächste Subscriber-Marke geknackt haben. Dass ich jetzt noch einen neuen Emote-Slot mit Emotes füllen muss. Muss, das hört sich so gezwungen an, als müsste ich das machen.
Oh nein, wir sind, Leute, wir sind 2 Abos. Wir sind 2 Abos. 2 Abos von neuer Subscriber-Marke für neues Emote. 2 Abos.
Oh nein. Oh, da haben wir es doch schon. Poggers, Alter, Poggers. Wen haben wir denn hier noch am Start?
Hast du eigentlich mal ein Video mit dem Kasten gemacht, der Informatik-Studierenden? Ne, noch nicht. Der drückt sich immer. Subscribers, wenn haben wir am Start. Cotton-Cori-Twitch-Prime. Nice, Dankeschön. Und Jay Eats.
Ah, Jay Eats. Ich sag einfach mal nur Jay. Ich hab mich gestern im Stream ein bisschen über diese ganze Overwatch-Geschichte ausgelassen. Und ich find's übelst, einfach nur Jays. Ich find's immer noch übelst erbärmlich oder schwach, sag mal mal, von Blizzard.
Die ganze Geschichte. Vor allem, dass ich jetzt gelesen hab, dass die Teams noch nicht mal was von den Trikot-Verkäufen abbekommen. Also das ist wirklich ganz schwach.
Deswegen, ich werd gucken, dass ich morgen ein Video dazu mach. Ich hab Blizzard angeschrieben. Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich noch mal das ein bisschen offizieller machen soll. Aber es hat wahrscheinlich eh keinen Sinn.
Weil die eh nicht antworten. Das heißt, es hat keinen Sinn da irgendwie drauf zu warten. Außerdem werden die da auch nichts dran ändern, bloß weil wir das scheiße finden.
Deswegen, das einzige, was mir übrig bleibt, ist eigentlich, meinem Unmut da auf YouTube mal ein bisschen Luft zu machen.
Kleine Indie-Firma, weißt du. So viele Infos, was Blizzard alles vermisst hat.
Glaub ich dir, würd mich auch nicht wundern. Aber in dem Fall geht's mir jetzt nur um die eine Geschichte mit dem World Cup. Und zumindest das, was jetzt schon raus ist über den Overwatch World Cup. Ich find das so fail.
Weißt du, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Spieler nicht nur kein Aufwandsentschädigung kriegen oder sagen wir mal kein Gehalt kriegen dafür, dass sie quasi die Show machen da für Blizzard.
Nein, doch viel schlimmer. Sie müssen es auch noch bezahlen, die Show machen zu dürfen für Blizzard. Und dann noch nicht mal was zu futtern zu kriegen, wenn sie rausfliegen bei einem bescheuerten Single Elimination Bracket.
Also wer sich das bei Blizzard ausgedacht hat, der ist wirklich Next Level Big Brain.
Freifert. Kein preisgend. Ja, das hab ich auch gelesen. Also Blizzard hat gesagt, ich hab nirgendwo Infos zu Price Money gefunden. Und selbst wenn, selbst wenn, sag mal mal, wenn du als Außenseiter-Team dahin fliegst, sagen wir 10-15k Ausgaben hast,
das höchste der Gefühle bei den Rängen, wo es eventuell Preisgeld gibt, wo du Chancen hast, wird sich höchstens in dem Bereich bewegen, dass du mit Ach und Krach, wenn du wirklich viel besser bist, als dir jemals zugetraut hätte,
kommst du in die Ränge, wo eventuell das Preisgeld so ist, dass du deinen Ausgang überhaupt nur ansatzweise gedeckt hast.
Das ist einfach Fail. Ich weiß nicht, was mit Blizzard los ist, vor allem ganz ehrlich, als würde das Blizzard jetzt großartig...
Alter, was geht mit meiner Maus ab? Die schwackt übelst rum. Das liegt hier an der komischen Logitech Maus.
Ich hab's mal ausgerechnet, wenn du 15k pro Team brauchst und sind 50 Teams, dann brauchst du 750k. 750k ist für Blizzard nix. Da lachen die sich drüber kaputt.
750k geben die wahrscheinlich für irgendeinen Stream von PewDiePie oder so aus. Keine Ahnung, aber das juckt die einfach nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die sich so anstellen.
Ja, und das kommt noch dazu, dass ich auch gelesen hab, dass der letzte World Cup irgendwie 3 viertel Jahre später ausbezahlt wurde
und teilweise manche Contender-Teams noch nicht mal ihr Geld haben. Also wirklich. Das ist echt...
Das ist schon nicht mal Big Brain. Das ist einfach unfähig.
Naja.
Ich hab jetzt glaube ich ein paar Subscribers vergessen.
Genau, Jayce, CottonCory hatten wir. Dankeschön für die Subs. Dann haben wir noch Failor verschenkt. Ein Stufe 1 Abo an die Community. Und wer kriegt das? Es kriegt das Neue Testament.
Das Neue Testament kriegt einen Sub. Das ist gut. Ich hoffe der Teufel bleibt jetzt hier fern. Und bei NumberOfTheBeast hatten wir vorhin schon als Sub.
Oje, das ist heute aber was. Warum spielt sich eigentlich auf der PS4-Code viel so schlecht mit Maus und Tastatur? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich weil die Abtastrate unter ihr nicht schlecht ist.
Ich brauch mehr Emotes. Ich weiß. Ich weiß.
Außerdem finde ich die Preisgelder bei Blizzard in Anbetracht der Sache, wenn man sich mal anguckt was Fortnite da rausgehauen hat auf der World Cup, schon ein bisschen low.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, dass ich dem Gewinner irgendwie eine Million geben soll. Vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ein bisschen was.
Ich mein die machen immerhin die übelste Show und den übelsten Hype für Blizzard.
Wer die mir? Das hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt.
Aber das glaub ich irgendwie auch nicht so richtig, weil ich mein Blizzard kann nicht erwarten, dass Content-Creator kostenlose Content machen.
Wenn Content-Creator kostenlos Content machen würde, gibt es bald keinen Content mehr, weil alle Content-Creator weg sind.
Man muss auch umsonst für Blizzard an der Gamescom arbeiten.
Ganz ehrlich Blizzard könnte mich mal so gerne haben, was das angeht.
Die kommst du auf 15k, weil das die Teams sagen, die hinfahren. Die ganzen Crowdfunding Ziele sind so irgendwas um 10 und 15k.
Und das deutsche Team hat auch gesagt, dass sie irgendwie so in der Regel in die Richtung was von 10 bis 15.000 Euro anstreben.
Ich mein man darf nicht vergessen, es sind die Spieler, es sind 8 Leute, es sind Spieler, es ist der Coach und wahrscheinlich der Team oder Community Manager.
Genau das heißt 7 oder 8 Leute. Das für ich weiß nicht wie lange die BlizzCon geht, irgendwie fast eine Woche oder so.
Also das Turnier fängt ja schon vor der BlizzCon an.
Ja CottonCory, Dankeschön für den Sub. Hab ich gar nicht erwähnt.
Habt ihr noch ein paar Infos zu Blizzard geschenkt? Habt ihr da markiert? Weiter oben.
Ich kenne die damals, die für Blizzard gearbeitet haben, persönlich mein Sprit bei allen, den puren Hass.
Also ganz ehrlich, die könnten mich mal gerne haben bei Blizzard, wenn ich da umsonst arbeiten sollte oder umsonst Content produzieren sollte.
Es sei denn man hat was davon.
Kashmoryk, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Ich wollte euch doch irgendwas erzählen, aber ich hab's vergessen.
Ich wollte eigentlich off und dann ist mir eingefallen, ich muss euch noch was erzählen, aber ich hab's vergessen.
Was wollte ich euch dann erzählen?
Ich muss mal den Chat durchscrollen, dann fällt es mir bestimmt wieder ein.
Wie viele durchschnittliche Spiele hat Overwatch? Ich glaube, es gibt keine Spielzahlen.
Ach ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich euch erzählen wollte.
Ich hab's euch ja schon erzählt, das letzte Mal.
Ich hab ja vor ungefähr einem Jahr eine Anfrage gekriegt.
Also ich mein, ich krieg per Mail laufend irgendwelche komischen Anfragen, wenn ich irgendwelche Mobile Games promoten will oder sowas.
Aber das sind so, wenn du einmal in diesen Mailverteilern gelandet bist, du kriegst immer was.
Selbst wenn du nichts machst auf YouTube und wenn du der uninteressanteste Channel auf der Welt kriegst, immer was.
Aber ab und zu kriegt man ein paar interessante, manchmal kommt dann auch was zustande.
Und vor einem Jahr hab ich, das hab ich euch im Stream damals gezeigt, vor einem Jahr hab ich die Anfrage gekriegt, ob ich nicht einen RGB Gaming Desk promoten möchte.
Und das haben wir uns damals angeguckt und haben uns ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht, warum man sowas braucht und wozu das da ist.
Und ich hab dann zurückgeschrieben damals, dass mir das nicht ganz einleuchtend, was auf der Seite steht.
Da stand ja sowas drin, wie von medizinischen Studien belegt oder sowas, bessere Sitzhaltung und bessere Reaktionszeit und bla und sonst was.
Ich hab halt damals zurückgeschrieben nach dem Motto, ok, ich kann das nicht ganz nachvollziehen, also auf was beziehen sie sich da, ob sie mir das mal schicken könnten oder ob ich das mal lesen könnte.
Und was mir auch nicht ganz klar ist, warum dieser Tisch jetzt quasi gerade für Gamer besser ist als ein Holztisch mit RGB außen vor, habe ich nie eine Antwort drauf gekriegt.
Und gestern oder vorgestern kriege ich eine Mail, die meine letzte Mail mit den ganzen Fragen drin quotet und die Fragen nicht beantwortet, die einfach nochmal eine Frage schickt.
Also nach dem Motto, ich hoffe unser Produkt hatte ich mittlerweile überzeugt, wir haben jetzt neue Modelle, hast du jetzt Interesse um Promotion mit uns zu machen?
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, absolut Pfeifert. Da habe ich jetzt nochmal zurückgeschrieben nach dem Motto, ok Leute, ist ja Gaming Desk schön und gut, aber warum genau, das geht für mich aus dieser Seite nicht hervor, warum genau ist der Gaming Desk von euch besser als ein stinknormaler Holztisch?
Ich habe es ein bisschen schöner formuliert, ja. Jetzt kriege ich wieder keine Antwort. Wenn die mir das sinnvoll begründen könnten, Leute, mache ich den Gaming Desk Sellout.
Das einzige, was daran Gaming ist, ist ein Getränkehalter, ein Controllerhalter, der sogar nur draufgestellt ist und ein Headsethalter.
Aber das ist jetzt ja nichts, warum ich mir einen extra Tisch kaufen müsste und RGB. Ja, die Optik vielleicht, wobei ich echt sagen muss, das sieht ziemlich wackelig aus.
Guckt euch mal die Füße an. Das sieht ziemlich wackelig aus.
Es gibt schon größere Sachen. Es gibt ja hier die XXL Edition in Blau.
Da passt schon ein bisschen was hin, aber ganz ehrlich, so wirklich den Vorteil sehe ich nicht, zumal man die RGB Beleuchtung, so wie es aussieht, auch mit keinerlei RGB Management Software integrieren kann.
Das würde nämlich heißen, ich brauche irgendeine ASUS Management Software, irgendeine Corsair Management Software, RGB, irgendeine Ultra Desk Gaming Management.
Ich brauche drei oder vier verschiedene RGB Software Geschichten, um eine RGB zu steuern. Das ist einfach bescheuert.
Dann die übliche Geschichte, dass wieder alles reduziert ist. Also ich hoffe, ich kriege darauf noch eine Antwort, weil mich das wirklich, also jetzt ernsthaft interessieren würde, was den Gaming Desk, also den Ultra Desk zum besseren Tisch macht als mein billig Holz Tisch hier.
Gibt es da Reviews? Ich weiß nicht, wir gucken mal bei Amazon. Ultra.
Oh, huge Reviews. Okay, mal Amazon Reviews angucken. Die schlechten Reviews sind eigentlich immer die interessantesten.
Bin, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön, Pok. Gucken, dass ich nichts übersehen habe.
Nee, zum Glück nicht. Aber Glück gehabt. Einfach klasse Gaming Tisch. Die Lieferung erfolgt schnell dank der Express League.
Hätte aber wahrscheinlich auch mit, vor allem, wer stellt denn seine PS4 auf den Tisch? Also ich meine, ich habe die PS4 hier neben auf so einem Rollcontainer stehen, meine Konsolen.
Warum soll ich hier auf den Tisch stellen? Den Platz brauche ich. Da steht mein Audiokrempel rum hier. Ultra Desk Gaming Tisch. Okay, mal gucken, ob sich das nach Fake Rezession liest, aber sieht nicht so aus.
Übrigens, genau den gleichen DX Racer Stuhl hatte ich auch davor, von meinem aktuellen hier, den ich jetzt habe. Also DX Racer Stühle sind auch so eine Gaming-Geschichte, die ich nicht empfehlen würde.
Der Stuhl an sich ist jetzt nicht ultra kacke oder so, der ist sogar relativ bequem, aber DX Racer, ich hatte genau den gleichen hier. Man sieht den zumindest sehr ähnlich. Das hat unten geklappert, das hat geknarzt und das Schlimmste ist, eines Tages beim Aufstehen ist einfach die komplette Armlehne rausgebrochen.
Nicht schmiese Quali. Und außerdem kam er schon mit kaputtem Polster an. Einfach eine Wäscheklammer. Ja, ist so. Ich finde diese Headset-Halterung und Controller-Halter, das ist komplett gimmick.
Nix, was ich jetzt irgendwie integriert bräuchte in den Tisch. Hast du mitbekommen, dass man bei Gigabyte, GPUs, Anzeigen, Firmen über die RGB-App flashen kann?
Zulu, echt? Lustig. Das finde ich cool, dass das funktioniert. Das finde ich witzig, das muss ich mal als Thema aufschreiben. Ich habe keine Gigabyte-GPU, aber das würde ich mal ausprobieren.
Naja, also was haben sie noch hier geschrieben? Ultrades Gaming Tisch, eine sehr gute Qualität, tolle Materialien und gut verarbeitet. Sieht sehr hochwertig aus, kommt als Geschenk prima an.
Na ja, ich kenne auch viele, die sich über den Tisch freuen. Ich habe online keinen besseren gefunden, der preis-sicher und optisch mithalten konnte.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, ich finde den Tisch optisch noch nicht mal sonderlich schick. Das ist quasi eine Platte mit Metallbeinen dran und ein bisschen Belichtung. Also ich finde nicht, dass das der große Designer-Wurf ist.
Optik-Top-Verarbeitung-Flop. Aha. Aber hochwertig für Audi.
Carbon-Optik sehr stark angekratzt, nicht nur ein bisschen, sondern extrem viele Kratzer. Die Kanten sind sehr schlecht verarbeitet, einfach nach des Preises wird der Tisch trotzdem weiter verarbeitet.
Das stimmt ja, das kommt ja noch dazu. 190 Euro für einen richtig ordentlichen Tisch ist tatsächlich nicht viel. Deswegen habe ich ja auch so meine Zweifel, ob der wirklich so geil ist, wie der ist.
Irgendwie finde ich das Ding jetzt nicht auf. Nicht gerade hochwertig. Ich hoffe die Antworten noch drauf.
Der Tisch ist mega nice zum zocken. Schön groß für drei Monitore. Getränkehalter mega nice. Absolute Kaufempfehlung. Also wenn ich den Getränkehalter am Tisch brauche, dann mache ich mir den einfach dran. Den brauche ich nicht.
Außerdem habe ich meinen Becher einfach, stellt es euch vor, einfach neben mir stehen. Ganz ohne Getränkehalter. Sachen gibt es, oder? Das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht möglich, ich weiß. Aber es funktioniert.
Carbon Design. Naja, mal gucken. Mal gucken, ob die drauf antworten. Wo habe ich denn mein Handy, da könnte ich mal gucken. Ich gucke mal kurz, ob die drauf geantwortet haben. Schauen wir mal.
Bei der Gelegenheit kann ich euch gerade nochmal erzählen, was ihr tolles mit Amazon Prime machen könnt, während ich hier gucke, ob die geantwortet haben, bis ich meine Gmail App gefunden habe.
Nämlich, wenn ihr Amazon Prime habt und ihr das noch nicht wusstet, man kann Amazon Prime verbinden mit Twitch und man kann dann einmal im Monat einen Streamer seiner Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen. Man selbst bekommt alle Vorteile, also sprich alle Emotes, alle anderweitigen Sachen, die es in diesem Channel gibt.
Umsonst, wohlgemerkt, Amazon bezahlt, quasi um zu sagen, auf Amazons Nacken, wie man das heutzutage so schön sagt. Das Streamer bekommt auch alle Vorteile. Und das Beste ist, ihr kriegt auch kein Abo irgendwie aufgedrückt, was ihr dran denken müsst zu kündigen, sondern könnt einfach dem Streamer eurer Wahl, eurem Lieblingsstreamer, könnt ihr unterstützen. Mit Twitch Prime. Das ist doch was, oder?
Never subbed free entertainment, ja, ich weiß. Die Leute, die copypast haben, brauchen wir jetzt mal eine Runde. Hat die jemand zur Hand?
Adblock on, never subbed free entertainment, mag G, Twitch Prime, dankeschön. Never subbed, never donated, adblock on, stolen, laptop, neighbors, wifi, free entertainment, genau, so ist das richtig.
Es gibt so viele nice copypasta Blödsinn für Twitch, ne? Also Ultra Desk hat nicht geantwortet.
Oh, what the fuck? Wisst ihr, was ich gerade feststelle? Wann hab ich das Rainbow Six, wann hab ich das Ghost Freak hochgeladen? Moment, ich hab noch keine Rechnung.
Sechster, vor 20 Tagen. Alter, Max, kannst du doch nicht machen. Rechnung schreiben. Das wäre wieder typisch Max, ne?
Das wäre wieder typisch Max Sellout machen und dann das Geld nicht kassieren. Das wäre wieder typisch Max Logik, ja.
Das hab ich bei Elgato auch ein Jahr lang mal geschafft. Ich hab den übelsten Elgato Sellout gemacht und hab nie die Kohle eingesammelt.
Allerdings war ich bei Elgato glücklicherweise darauf vorbereitet, dass ich's verkackt habe und hab's mir einfach nächstes Jahr gegeben.
Darfst du eigentlich drüber reden, was du kriegst? Klar. Also es sei denn, es steht explizit drinnen. Und bei den meisten Sachen steht's drinnen, dass das confidential ist.
Weiß ich warum. Dass wir ein Secret ummachen. Es ist mittlerweile für das, was man machen muss, echt...
Also ich kann mich da noch früher dran erinnern, wo du ein Spiel gekriegt hast und hast dich gefreut, dass du ein Spiel umsonst gekriegt hast oder du hast eine Maus gekriegt.
Oder das Höchste der Gefühle, du hast eine Grafikkarte gekriegt, da bist du komplett auseskaliert, ja. Und heute kriegst du quasi vierstellige Beträge für ein Video.
Aber Details darf ich in dem Fall echt nicht verraten, weil's drin steht.
Das ist halt echt der Wahnsinn, ey. Wo ich mir so denke, da hat sich ganz schön entwickelt diese Geschichte die letzten Jahre.
Auch ich mein, meine Katze ist so niedlich, oder? Sagt doch mal, Leute. So eine feine Katze hier.
So eine...
Nehm noch mal meine Discord-Anfrage an, mach ich.
Ja gut, Twitch darf ich verraten. Twitch ist einfach, äh, Abo-Anzahl mal 2,5. Äh, YouTube darf ich auch verraten. YouTube kann ich euch sagen, ich muss kurz reingucken.
Weiß ja, die Leute sehen immer Kraft drauf, das zu erfahren. Äh, AdSense Analytics. 545 Dollar YouTube AdSense.
Dazu kommt halt diese Ubisoft-Ghost-Tricken-Geschichte und ein bisschen Reflink-Krempel.
Also ich finde, es ist echt in Ordnung für das, dass ich das erst einen Monat wieder mache. Bin ich mit dem Progress echt zufrieden.
Und das geht nur, weil wir Big IQ Q-Chat haben.
Kommst du noch Eats auf Max-Steuersatz? Oh, hör mal auf. Ich muss die Woche meine Steuererklärung für letztes Jahr machen.
Da hab ich ja Bock drauf.
Da hab ich so keinen Bock drauf.
Steuererklärung ist immer das Schlimmste, wobei ich muss die Steuererklärung ja nicht mal selbst machen.
Ich muss aber die ganzen Belege zusammen suchen. Das ist echt Horror für mich immer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auf der Welt einen gibt, der gerne Steuererklärung macht.
Brauchst du Tipps? Nee, ich hab ja einen Steuerberater, aber ich muss halt die ganzen Belegekram zusammen suchen.
E-Mails durch Forsten nach irgendwelchen Sachen, die ich gekauft hab und boah ey, ich könnte kotzen, wenn ich dran denke.
Mode, Failure. Geil. Mode, Unbenennung, Max-Steuersatz.
Was hältst du von Steuererklärungs-Apps? Keine Ahnung, ich lasse das schon seitdem ich hier die Firma gegründet hab für YouTube.
Also meine Ein-Mann-Klitsche lasse ich das schon vom Steuerberater machen, weil ich keinen Bock hab, mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Ist das eine neue Katze? Nee, das ist die von der Nachbarin. Die von der Nachbarin war die hier.
Und Barbie war das hier. Ich weiß nicht warum man seine Katze Barbie nennt, aber die hieß halt schon so.
Das war leider unglücklich mit den anderen beiden. Ich meine, das sind alles alte Katzen, die sind auch schon wieder 10 oder so.
Bei alten Katzen kann es halt immer ganz schnell gehen. Richtiger Fields Batman.
Deine Katze heißt Mausi. Ja, warum nicht? Mausi find ich ein guter Katze. Sie heißt Chico.
Auch wenn ich immer noch finde, dass Chico irgendwie ein Männername ist, aber wie gesagt, sie reagiert halt drauf.
Na Chico, was ist los? Dann klotzst du dich an und kommst gleich angeeiert.
Deine Katze heißt Belloch. Ja, das ist Meta-Naming. Deine Katze heißt Max. Einfach Fettsack, denn dann reagiert die Katze.
Das sag ich auch manchmal zu meiner Katze. Ich sag zu meiner Katze nicht Fettsack, ich sag dicke Wurst.
Da guckt sie dann immer. Da guckt sie immer so abwertend.
Wenn ich sag, Alter, bist du wieder eine dicke Wurst, klotzst du mich an und sag, Alter, was erzählst du da für einen Scheiß? Guck dich mal selber an.
Dann denk ich mir mal, Alter, krass gedisst die Katze. Also mich. Obwohl sie gar nichts sagt, aber sie guckt so, als ob sie das sagen würde.
Okay Leute, bei Stocks würdest du mehr Dollar bekommen.
Ja, mit Sicherheit. Ja, das ist auch eine Geschichte, wo ich echt gucken muss.
Die nächsten paar Monate. Ich hab mir vorgenommen, dass ich die Kohle, die ich noch auf dem Konto rumliegen hab, in irgendwelche Sachen investiere.
Dass ich mindestens weniger Geld habe über die Jahre hinweg dann. Und dass es nicht weniger wird.
Oder ich mach einfach auf Twitch Slots. Dann verlier ich das Geld auch, krieg aber viele Viewer.
Und dann muss ich mir noch irgendwas auf die Backe tätowieren. Gehört sich anscheinend. Ich lass mir da MonkaS auf die Backe tätowieren.
FIFA. Ich wüsste gar nicht bei was ich mich mehr überwinden müsste. Bei Slots oder FIFA.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, was mich mehr quälen würde. Backe vorne oder hinten. Hälfte, Hälfte.
Du könntest bestimmt auch gut Geld machen, wenn du Slots programmierst.
Ich hab mir überlegt, wir haben ja letztens abends gestreamt, wo dann hier der Dingster, der Isle of Cookies, aufgetaucht ist.
Und wir haben uns spontan im Stream irgendwie überlegt, wir könnten ja mal was zusammen aufnehmen.
Allerdings hab ich mir im Nachhinein überlegt, ey wir können garantiert nichts zu Kot oder irgendwelches Game aufnehmen.
Weil ich mein, der spielt ja nix mehr. Der spielt ja nur Poker.
Da hab ich mir überlegt, man könnte sich einfach mal mit ihm drüber unterhalten.
Und mich würd das mal interessieren, aus der Sicht von einem Pokerspieler, was der zu Pokerbots sagt.
Weil mich wunderts eigentlich, dass bei Pokerspielen noch nicht die Bots regieren.
Wundert mich echt, mich würd auch interessieren, was die dagegen machen.
Weil Poker müsste eigentlich ein Spiel sein, was geradezu gemacht ist für Bots.
Im Prinzip ist es ja, wie gesagt, Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung.
Warst du schon einmal in einem richtigen Casino? Ja, war ich.
Aber schon ne ganze Weile her.
Aber ich bin keiner, der irgendwie auf Glücksspiel anspringt.
Das einzige Glücksspiel, worauf ich anspringe sind Loot Games.
Sowas wie Pass of Exile oder so.
Das ist das einzige Glücksspiel, worauf ich anspringe.
RL Glücksspiel an Automatenspielen geht mir voll am Arsch vorbei.
Was würd's denn bringen, für Pokerbots zu haben? Na, Geld.
Der Bot müsste, natürlich müsste der Bot bewusst verlieren.
Der müsste sagen, okay, mit diesen Karten, das was ich gesehen hab, bestehen meine Chancen nicht gut.
Für den und den Einsatz, ich mach die Runde nicht mit.
Und ich verstehe nicht, weil für mich sieht Poker nach nem Game aus, was eigentlich übelst von Bots dominiert werden müsste.
Und mich würde interessieren, warum nicht und was er dazu sagt, würde mich echt mal interessieren.
Ich raff überhaupt nämlich nicht, wie man von Poker leben kann.
Man muss einfach gut Poker spielen, gewisse Risikobereitschaft haben und eben ein paar viele Glücksspiele.
Poker, für mich ist es noch nicht mal so richtig Glücksspiel.
Es hat ja schon gewisse Brain Komponente dahinter.
Ich hab gelesen, dass beispielsweise der Großteil unserer Nationalmannschaft mit Poker Geld verdient.
Also Big Brain hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass man davon leben kann.
Wie das bei random basierten Sachen so ist, man muss einfach nur möglichst viel spielen.
Es ist bei allen Sachen so, es ist ein bisschen wie bei Hearthstone im Endeffekt.
Hearthstone ist auch ein Skillspiel, allerdings ist Hearthstone so krass random, so übertrieben scheiß random,
dass du halt einfach mal 20.000 Games spielen musst, dass du wirklich weißt, wer von beiden besser ist.
Wenn die ähnlich gut sind.
BeatBroad, ich glaube das musst du gar nicht wissen mit einem Bot.
Ich glaube mit einem Bot spielst du einfach rein auf Wahrscheinlichkeiten und wenn es so aussieht, als kackst du ab.
Weil ich mein, ganz ehrlich, bei irgendwelchen Online-Turnieren oder so, du kannst dir den anderen Typ ja auch nicht angucken.
Du siehst ja irgendein Avatar Bild oder so.
Das müsstest du eigentlich rein auf Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnungen basteln, den Bot.
Und deswegen, vielleicht verstehe ich es auch einfach nur nicht.
Es ist viel, viel komplizierter, als ich mir das vorstelle, einen Poker-Bot zu programmieren, aber ich verstehe nicht.
Also ich würde vermuten, dass eigentlich Online-Poker komplett dominiert sein müsste von Bots.
Aber ist es anscheinend nicht und ich weiß halt nicht warum.
Ja.
Ja, ist fertig.
Gucken wir uns vielleicht morgen im Stream an und wie gesagt, ich muss noch ein Video machen.
Aber ich muss Video machen zu der Overwatch-Geschichte und zu den Call of Duty-Geschichten, die gerade so anstehen.
Wie diese Konsolenexklusivität und das Survival-Konsolenexklusiv ist, die Lootbox-Geschichte.
Aber morgen mache ich auf jeden Fall die Geschichte zum Overwatch World Cup, weil mich Blizzard übelst ankotzt.
Was glaubst du, warum Online-High-Speed-Trading nicht von Bots dominiert wird?
Wird es doch wahrscheinlich.
Wird es bestimmt.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn den fetteren Rechner und die schnellere Software hat, wird gewinnen.
Also im Prinzip.
Und da wird es bestimmt auch Software haben, die ganz automatisch entscheidet, was gekauft wird und verkauft wird.
Ich würde mich wundern, wenn da nicht Bots dominieren.